Der kleine Prinz von Anton de Saint Exculperie
Mit Illustrationen des Autors
Gelesen von Joachim Friedrich
Erstes Kapitel
Als ich sechs war, sah ich einmal ein wunderbares Bild in einem Buch über den Dschungel.
Das wahre Geschichten hieß.
Auf dem Bild war eine Königsschlange, die gerade ein wildes Tier verschlingen wollte.
Hier ist eine Kopie des Bildes.
In diesem Buch heißt es, Boas verschlingen ihre Beute als Ganzes ohne zu kauen.
Danach können sie sich nicht mehr bewegen und schlafen sechs Monate zur Verdauung.
Ich grübelte daher viel über die Ereignisse im Dschungel.
Mit einem Farbstift gelang mir meine erste Zeichnung.
Meine Zeichnung Nummer eins. Sie sah so aus.
Ich legte mein Meisterwerk den großen Leuten vor und fragte sie, ob ihnen die Zeichnung nicht Angst mache.
Sie sagten, warum sollten wir Angst vor einem Hut bekommen?
Meine Zeichnung stellte aber gar keinen Hut dar.
Es war eine Riesenschlange, die einen Elefanten verdaut.
Ich zeichnete also das Innere der Boa, damit es die großen Leute genau erkannten.
Denn sie brauchen immer Erklärungen.
Meine Zeichnung Nummer zwei sah so aus.
Die großen Leute rieten mir dann, das Zeichnen von offenen oder geschlossenen Boas bleiben zu lassen
und mich mehr mit Geografie, Geschichte, Mathematik und Grammatik zu beschäftigen.
So kam es, dass ich im Alter von sechs eine wunderbare Karriere als Male aufgab.
Ich hatte durch das Scheitern meiner Zeichnungen Nummer eins und Nummer zwei meinen ganzen Mut verloren.
Die großen Leute verstehen nie etwas von selbst.
Und für die Kinder ist es viel zu mühevoll, ihnen die Dinge immer und immer wieder von Neuem zu erklären.
Ich musste mir also einen anderen Beruf fehlen und ich lernte Flugzeuge zu fliegen.
Ich flog durch die ganze Welt.
Die Geografie, das ist richtig, hat mir gute Dienste dabei geleistet.
Auf den ersten Blick kann ich nun China von Arizona unterscheiden.
Das ist besonders hilfreich, wenn man sich in der Nacht verirrt hat.
In meinem Leben lernte ich viele bedeutende Menschen kennen, ich lebte mit ihnen zusammen und beobachtete sie ganz genau.
Doch an meiner Meinung über sie änderte sich nichts.
Immer wenn ich jemanden traf, der mir ein wenig schlauer vorkam, zeigte ich meine Zeichnung Nummer eins, die ich mir dafür aufgehoben hatte.
Ich wollte wissen, ob er sie verstand.
Aber alle antworteten sie nur, dies ist ein Hut.
Dann wusste ich, dass ich mit diesen Leuten nicht über Boas oder den Dschungel reden konnte.
Mit ihnen sprach ich über Brettspiele, Golf, Politik und Krawatten.
Die großen Leute waren dann immer froh, einen vernünftigen Mann kennengelernt zu haben.
Zweites Kapitel.
So kam es, dass ich allein lebte und niemanden hatte, mit dem ich mich wirklich unterhalten konnte.
Bis ich vor sechs Jahren in der Sahara eine Panne hatte.
Etwas in meinem Motor war gebrochen, weil ich aber weder ein Mechaniker noch Passagiere anbord hatte,
machte ich mich ganz allein an die schwierige Reparatur.
Es ging für mich um Leben oder Tod, denn ich hatte Trinkwasser für nur acht Tage.
Tausend Meilen von jeder bewohnten Gegend entfernt schlief ich in der ersten Nacht im Sand.
Ich fühlte mich einsamer als ein schiffbrüchiger Matrose auf einem Floß im Ozean.
Umso größer war meine Überraschung, als mich bei Sonnenaufgang eine seltsam kleine Stimme weckte.
Sie sagte, bitte zeichne mir ein Schaf.
Hä? Zeichne mir ein Schaf.
Ich sprang auf die Füße, als hätte mich der Blitz getroffen.
Ich rieb mir die Augen und schaute ganz genau hin.
Da entdeckte ich einen kleinen, außergewöhnlichen Mann, der mich ernst betrachtete.
Dies ist das beste Porträt, das mir später von ihm gelang.
Aber meine Zeichnung ist bestimmt nicht so liebenswürdig wie das Original.
Das ist aber nicht meine Schuld.
Als ich im Alter von sechs und den Leuten ganz entmutigt meine Karriere als Mahler aufgab,
konnte ich nichts weiterzeichnen als offene und geschlossene Riesenschlangen.
Mit großen Augen starte ich also diese Gestalt an.
Vergess dabei nicht, da sich Tausend Meilen von jeder bewohnten Gegend entfernt war.
Einigene Mann schien sich weder verirrt zu haben, noch sah er totmüde, verhungert, verdurstet oder ängstlich aus.
Er sah nicht wie ein verlorenes Kind in der Wüste aus, das Tausend Meilen von jeder menschlichen Behausung entfernt war.
Als ich meine Sprache wiedergewann, sagte ich zu ihm, aber was machst du denn hier?
Und dann wiederholte er langsam, als wäre es eine sehr ernste Sache.
Bitte zeichne mir ein Schaf.
Wenn etwas Geheimnisvolles besonders beeindruckend ist, kann man nicht widerstehen.
So absurd es mir auch erschien, in Todesgefahr, Tausend Meilen von jeder menschlichen Behausung entfernt.
Ich nahm aus meiner Tasche ein Blatt Papier und einen Füllfederhalter.
Doch dann erinnerte ich mich wieder, dass ich vor allem Geografie, Geschichte, Mathematik und Grammatik studiert hatte.
So sagte ich dem kleinen Kerl ein wenig verärgert, dass ich nicht zeichnen könne.
Er antwortete, kein Problem, zeichne mir ein Schaf.
Da ich noch nie ein Schaf gezeichnet hatte, zeichnete ich ihm eines der beiden Bilder, die ich nur zeichnen konnte.
Das von der Boa.
Ich war sehr erstaunt, als ich den kleinen Mann sagen hörte, will ich nicht, will ich nicht.
Ich will kein Elefanten in einer Riesenschlange.
Eine Boa ist sehr gefährlich und ein Elefant braucht zu viel Platz.
Bei mir zu Hause ist es viel zu klein.
Ich brauche ein Schaf, zeichne mir ein Schaf.
Also zeichnete ich eines.
Er saß aufmerksam an und sagte, will ich nicht, das ist sehr krank, zeichne ein anderes.
Ich zeichnete dieses.
Mein Freund lächelte nun sanft und nachsichtig.
Sie doch.
Das ist kein Schaf, es ist ein Wider.
Er hat Hörner.
Also machte ich noch eine weitere Zeichnung.
Aber auch sie wurde abgelehnt, wie die beiden zuvor.
Dieses ist zu alt, ich will ein Schaf, das noch lange leben wird.
Mir ging nun die Geduld aus, denn ich musste ja unbedingt meinen Motor reparieren.
So kritzelte ich diese Zeichnung.
Und ich berummte, das ist eine Kiste, das Schaf, das du willst, ist dort drin.
Ich war sehr überrascht, als ich das Gesicht meines jungen Kritikers aufhälte.
Es ist ganz so, wie ich es wollte.
Glaubst du, dass das Schaf viel Gras benötigt?
Warum?
Da, wo ich liebe, ist alles sehr klein.
Es wird sicher genug haben, es ist ein kleines Schaf.
Er beugte sich über die Zeichnung.
Nicht so klein wie?
Schau nur.
Es ist eingeschlafen?
So machte ich meine Bekanntschaft mit dem kleinen Prinzen.
Drittes Kapitel
Es dauerte lange, bis ich verstand, woher er kam.
Der kleine Prinz, der mir so viele Fragen stellte,
schien mir selbst nie zuzuhören.
Stück für Stück offenbarten sich mir seine Worte.
Ich hatte zum ersten Mal mein Flugzeug sah.
Ich werde keine Zeichnung von meinem Flugzeug machen.
Das ist mir viel zu kompliziert.
Fragte er mich, was ist das für ein Ding?
Das ist kein Ding.
Es fliegt.
Das ist ein Flugzeug.
Es ist mein Flugzeug.
Und ich war stolz ihm zu sagen, dass ich fliege.
Da sagte er, wie?
Bist du vom Himmel gefallen?
Ja, sagte ich Bescheiden.
Ah, das ist lustig.
Da bekam der kleine Prinz einen riesigen Lachanfall,
was mich sehr verärgerte.
Ich wünschte mir, dass er mein Unglück ernst nehmen würde.
Da sagte er noch, du kommst also auch aus dem Himmel?
Von welchem Planeten bist du denn her?
Da ging mir ein Licht über das Geheimnis seiner Herkunft auf.
Und ich fragte eilig, kommst du etwa von einem anderen Planeten?
Er antwortete aber nicht und schüttelte nur unwillig den Kopf,
während er mein Flugzeug betrachtete.
Ehrlich, mit diesem Ding kann man nicht von sehr weit hergekommen sein.
So versank er in Träumerei, was lange Zeit andauerte.
Dann zog er mein Schaf aus der Tasche und stürzte sich in den Anblick seines Schatzes.
Ihr könnt euch sicher vorstellen, wie stark meine Neugier durch diese Andeutung
der anderen Planeten in mir geweckt wurde.
Ich bemühte mich daher, um mehr zu erfahren.
Wo kommst du her, kleiner Mann?
Wo ist deine Heimat?
Wohin willst du mein Schaf mitnehmen?
Nach einem nachdenklichen Schweigen antwortete er,
das Gute an der Kiste, die du mir gegeben hast, ist,
dass es ihm in der Nacht sein Haus sein kann.
Sicher!
Und wenn du artig bist, schenke ich dir ein Streck,
an den du es am Tag anbinden kannst, und einen Pflok dazu.
Dieser Vorschlag schockierte den Klein Prinzen.
Anbinden? Was für eine seltsame Idee!
Wenn du es aber nicht anbindest, wird es fortlaufen und sich verirren.
Da bekam ein Freund einen weiteren Lachanfall.
Wo soll es denn hinlaufen?
Überall? Geradeaus?
Da entgegnete der kleine Prinz sehr ernst.
Das spielt keine Rolle.
Bei mir zu Hause ist es sehr klein.
Und erfügte, vielleicht ein wenig traurig hinzu,
geradeaus kann man nicht sehr weit kommen.
Viertes Kapitel.
Ich hatte eine zweite sehr wichtige Sache gelernt.
Sein Heimatplanet war kaum größer als sein Haus.
Das erschien mir wirklich sehr seltsam.
Ich wusste zwar,
dass es außer den großen Planeten wie Erde,
Jupiter, Mars und Venus,
denen man bereits Namen gegeben hatte,
noch hunderte von anderen Planeten gibt,
die manchmal so klein sind,
dass man sie kaum im Fernrohr sehen kann.
Wenn ein Astronom einen von ihnen entdeckt,
gibt er ihm eine Zahl.
Zum Beispiel nennt er ihn Asteroid N. 3251.
Ich habe also ernsthafte Gründe zu der Annahme,
dass der Planet, von dem der kleine Prinz kam,
der Asteroid B. 612 ist.
Dieser Asteroid war einst im Jahre 1909
von einem türkischen Astronomen entdeckt worden.
Auf dem internationalen Kongress der Astronomen
hatte er einen großen Vortrag über seine Entdeckung gehalten.
Aber niemand hatte ihm allein seiner Trachtwegen
Glauben geschenkt.
So sind die großen Leute.
Für den Ruf des Planeten B. 612 war es ein Glück,
das einst der türkische Herrscher seinem Volk
die Androhung der Todesstrafe befahl,
fortan nur noch europäische Kleider zu tragen.
Im Jahre 1920 hielt der Astronom seinen Vortrag nun
in einem sehr eleganten Anzug noch ein weiteres Mal.
Und dieses Mal glaubten sie ihm alle,
wenn ich euch alle diese Einzelheiten über den Asteroid B. 612 erzähle
und euch seine Nummer verrate,
geschieht dies der großen Leute wegen.
Die großen Leute lieben nämlich Zahlen.
Wenn ihr euch über einen neuen Freund unterhaltet,
wollen sie nie das Wesentliche wissen.
Sie fragen dich nie, wie ist der Klang seiner Stimme?
Welche Spiele liebt er am meisten?
Sammelt er Schmetterlinge?
Sie wollen lieber wissen, wie alt ist er,
wie viele Brüder hat er, wie viel wiegt er,
wie viel verdient sein Vater
und dann werden sie glauben, ihn zu kennen.
Und wenn ihr den großen Leuten erzählt,
ich habe ein sehr schönes Haus mit roten Ziegeln gesehen,
mit Geranien vor dem Fenster und Tauben auf dem Dach,
werden sie sich das Haus nicht vorstellen können.
Ihr müsst viel mehr sagen,
ich habe ein Haus gesehen, das 100.000 Franken wert ist.
Dann greichen sie gleich, oh, wie schön!
So ist es auch, wenn ihr ihnen sagt,
der Beweis dafür, dass es den kleinen Prinzen wirklich gab,
besteht darin, dass er zauberhaft war,
dass er lachte und ein Schaf haben wollte.
Und wenn jemand ein Schaf haben will,
ist das der Beweis dafür, dass es einen gibt.
Dann werden sie nur mit den Schultern zucken
und behandeln euch wie kleine Kinder.
Wenn er ihnen aber sagt, der Planet, von dem er her kam,
ist der Asteroid B612,
dann würden sie überzeugt davon sein
und euch keine Fragen mehr stellen.
So sind sie, wir dürfen es ihnen nicht verübeln,
denn Kinder müssen mit den großen Leuten viel Nachsicht üben.
Wir, die wir wissen, was das Leben bedeutet,
scheren uns nicht um zu viele Fragen.
Diese Geschichte hätte ich auch viel lieber wie ein Märchen begonnen.
Ich hätte gern gesagt, es war einmal ein kleiner Prinz.
Der lebte auf einem Planeten, der kaum größer war als er selbst.
Und er brauchte einen Freund.
Für diejenigen, die das Leben wirklich verstehen,
würde sich dies viel besser anhören.
Ich möchte nicht, dass man mein Buch zu leicht hinnimmt.
Es macht mich so traurig, von diesen Erinnerungen zu erzählen.
Es ist nun schon sechs Jahre her,
als mein Freund mit seinem Schaf davon zog.
Ich erzähle dies vor allem, um ihn nicht zu vergessen,
denn es ist traurig, einen Freund zu vergessen.
Aber nicht jeder hat einen Freund gehabt.
Und ich möchte nicht, wie die großen Leute werden,
die sich nur für die Zahlen interessieren.
Genau deshalb habe ich mir auch einen Farbkasten
und ein paar Bleistifte gekauft.
Es ist schwer, in meinem Alter wieder mit dem Zeichen zu beginnen.
Erst recht, wenn ich seit meinem sechsten Lebensjahr
nichts anderes versucht hatte, als eine offene und eine geschlossene Bohr.
Natürlich will ich die Porträt so gut wie möglich machen,
aber ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob ich das erreichen werde.
Wenn die eine Zeichnung halbwegs geht,
ist die nächste schon kaum mehr zu erkennen.
Auch bei den Maßstäben mache ich mit Unterfehler.
Mal ist der kleine Prinz zu groß, mal ist er zu klein.
Und bei den Farben seiner Kleider hege ich genauso Zweifel.
So probiere ich dies und das.
Selbst bei wichtigen Details mache ich bestimmt so einige Fehler,
aber das muss man mir verzeihen.
Ich habe nie Erklärungen von meinem Freund erhalten.
Er dachte wahrscheinlich, ich würde wie er sein.
Doch ich kann nicht wie er durch eine Kiste hindurch ein Schaf sehen.
Da bin ich vielleicht ein wenig wie die großen Leute.
Die Zeit verschonte mich nicht und ich wurde älter.
Fünftes Kapitel.
Jeden Tag lernte ich etwas Neues über seine Welt
und den Beginn seiner Reise.
Seine Gedanken kamen langsam und eher zufällig.
So erfuhr ich am dritten Tag von der Tragödie der Affenbrotbäume.
Auch dies verdankte ich dem Schaf,
denn der kleine Prinz fragte mich ganz unverhofft,
als wäre er von schweren Zweifeln geplagt.
Es stimmt doch, dass die Schafe Sträucher fressen?
Ja, das ist wahr.
Ah, da bin ich aber froh.
Ich verstand nicht ganz, warum es so wichtig war,
dass Schafe kleine Sträucher fressen.
Aber der kleine Prinz fügte hinzu.
Dann fressen sie bestimmt auch Affenbrotbäume.
Ich erklärte dem kleinen Prinzen,
dass Affenbrotbäume keine Sträucher sind,
da sie so groß wie Kirchen wären.
Selbst wenn er eine ganze Herde Elefanten mitbrechte,
würden sie einen Affenbrotbaum nicht fressen können.
Meine Idee mit den Elefanten brachte ihn zum Lachen.
Vielleicht sollte man sie übereinanderstellen.
Aber dann kam ihm ein kluger Gedanke.
Bevor die Affenbrotbäume groß werden, beginnen sie klein zu wachsen.
Das ist richtig, aber warum willst du,
dass dein Schaf kleine Affenbrotbäume aufriss?
Er antwortete, schon gut, lass es.
Er sagte es gerade so, als wäre es die normalste Sache von der Welt.
Mich aber kostete es die größte geistige Anstrengung,
diese Sache zu verstehen.
Tatsächlich gab es auf dem Planeten des kleinen Prinzen,
wie auf allen Planeten, gute Pflanzen und schädliche Pflanzen.
Und deshalb auch gute Samen von guten Pflanzen
und schädliche Samen von schädlichen Pflanzen.
Samen aber sind unsichtbar.
Sie schlafen geheimnisvoll in der Erde,
bis es einem von ihnen gefällt aufzuwachen.
Dann rägt er sich und streckt zunächst einen reizenden kleinen,
harmlosen Zweig zackhaft der Sonne entgegen.
Handelt es sich dabei um einen Zweig von Radieschen
oder einen von Rosen, kann man ihn wachsen lassen, wie er will.
Wenn es sich aber um eine schädliche Pflanze handelt,
muss man sie schon als Spross herausreißen.
Auf dem Planeten des kleinen Prinzen gab es schrägliche Samen.
Das waren die Samen der Affenbrotbäume.
Der Boden seines Planeten war ganz überdeckt von ihnen
und wenn es zu spät ist, wird man einen Affenbrotbaum dort niemals mehr los.
Er erstreckt sich über den ganzen Planeten
und durchbohrt ihn mit seinen Wurzeln.
Und wenn der Planet so klein ist
und zu viele Affenbrotbäume auf ihm wachsen,
kann er explodieren.
Das ist eine Frage der Disziplin,
erzählte mir der kleine Prinz später.
Wenn du deine Morgentorte beendet hast,
musst du dich gleich an die Pflege deines Planeten machen.
Die Triebe der Affenbrotbäume muss man sobald wie möglich ziehen,
sobald man sie von den Rosensträuchern unterscheiden kann.
Wenn sie jung sind, kann man sie kaum voneinander unterscheiden.
Dies ist eine sehr mühsame Arbeit, aber auch sehr einfach.
Und eines Tages riet er mir,
dass ich eine schöne Zeichnung davon machen solle,
damit die Kinder in meiner Heimat es auch ja richtig in den Kopf bekommen würden.
Wenn sie eines Tages auf Reisen gehen, sagt er zu mir,
könnte ihnen das nützlich sein.
Wenn man seine Arbeit auch mal einfach bleiben lässt,
ist das kein Problem.
Aber bei einem Affenbrotbaum führt das immer zur Katastrophe.
Ich kannte einmal einen Planeten, auf dem ein Faulpels lebte.
Er hatte drei Sträucher übersehen.
Und so zeichnete ich diesen Planeten, wie ihn mir der kleine Prinz beschrieb.
Ich mag es nicht, den Ton eines Moralisten einzunehmen,
aber die Gefahren, die von Affenbrotbäumen ausgehen,
sind so wenig bekannt.
Und die Gefahren auf einem Asteroiden sind so beträchtlich,
dass ich mich dieses einmal aus der Reserve locken lasse.
Darum sage ich, Kinder hütet euch vor Affenbrotbäumen,
um meine Freunde auf diese unbekannte Gefahr aufmerksam zu machen.
Die ihnen, wie auch mir droht, habe ich sehr lange an meiner Zeichnung gearbeitet.
Die Lehre, die ich damit gebe, ist aller Mühe wert.
Ihr fragt euch nun vielleicht,
warum sind in diesem Buch nicht noch andere so großartige Zeichnungen enthalten,
wie die der Affenbrotbäume?
Die Antwort darauf ist sehr einfach.
Ich habe es versucht, aber es wollte mir nicht gelingen.
Als ich die Affenbrotbäume zeichnete,
war ich von einem Gefühl größter Bedeutsamkeit belebt.
Sechs des Kapitel
Ja, kleiner Prinz, Stück für Stück verstand ich dein kleines melakolisches Leben.
Lange Zeit waren dir die sanften Sonnenuntergänge die einzige Zerstreuung.
Ich erfuhr dies am Morgen des vierten Tages, als du mir sagtest,
ich liebe Sonnenuntergänge, lass uns einen Sonnenuntergang anschauen.
Wir müssen aber noch warten.
Warten auf was?
Warten bis die Sonne untergeht.
Im ersten Augenblick warst du sehr erstaunt,
doch dann hast du über dich gelacht und du sagst es zu mir.
Ich glaube immer ich wäre zu Hause.
Tatsächlich, wie jeder man weiß, geht in Frankreich die Sonne unter,
wenn es in Amerika Mittag ist.
Um dort einen Sonnenuntergang beobachten zu können,
müsste man in einer Minute nach Frankreich fliegen können.
Aber zum großen Unglück ist Frankreich viel zu weit weg.
Doch auf deinem kleinen Planeten
brauchtest du nur deinen Stuhl um einige Schritte weiterrücken.
So erlebstest du die Dämmerung, wann immer du es wolltest.
Eines Tages sah ich den Sonnenuntergang 44 mal.
Und ein wenig später fügtest du hinzu.
Du weißt doch, wenn man sehr traurig ist,
hat man Sonnenuntergänge besonders gern.
Am Tag der 44 Mal warst du da besonders traurig.
Doch darauf gab der kleine Prinz keine Antwort.
Siebtes Kapitel.
Am fünften Tag verhelf mir wieder das Schaf dabei,
ein weiteres Geheimnis aus dem Leben des kleinen Prinzen zu entlocken.
Plötzlich, ohne Umschweife, fragte er mich,
als pflückte er die Frucht eines lange schweigend überlegten Problems.
Ein Schaf, wenn es Sträucher frisst, frisst es auch Blumen.
Ein Schaf frisst alles, was es sieht.
Auch Blumen, die Dornen haben?
Ja, auch Blumen, die Dornen haben.
Wofür sind dann die Dornen?
Ich hatte keine Ahnung.
Ich hatte gerade sehr damit zu tun,
einen festgezogenen Bolzen vom neuen Motor abzubekommen.
Es machte mir große Sorgen.
Meine Panne wurde immer bedenklicher,
und das Schlimmste dabei war, dass mein Trinkwasser zur Neige ging.
Wofür sind Dornen gut?
Der kleine Prinz vergaß nie eine Frage, wenn er sie gefragt hatte.
Ich war ganz mit meinem Bolzen beschäftigt,
und sagte einfach, irgendetwas.
Die Dornen haben gar keinen Zweck.
Das ist reine Boßheit der Blumen.
Oh!
Nach einer Weile wendete er sich mit einer bestimmten Art von Empörung an mich.
Ich glaube dir nicht.
Blumen sind schwach.
Sie sind einfältig.
Sie schützen sich so gut sie können.
Sie glauben, dass ihre Dornen abschrecken.
Ich schwieg.
In diesem Moment dachte ich mir,
wenn dieser Bolzen jetzt nicht nachgibt,
muss ich ihn mit einem Hammer herausschlagen.
Da unterbrach mich der kleine Prinz erneut in meinen Gedanken.
Glaubst du wirklich das Blumen?
Nein, aber nein, ich glaube nichts.
Ich habe das nur so gesagt.
Ich habe nur gerade wichtigere Dinge zu tun.
Er sah mich erstaunt an.
Wichtigere Dinge?
Er sah mich an, wie ich mich mit meinem Hammer in der Hand
und mit schwarzen Fingern voller Schmierfett über etwas beugte,
was ihm sehr hässlich erscheinen mußte.
Du redest ja wie die großen Leute.
Das beschämte mich ein wenig.
Er warmungslos fügte er hinzu.
Du verdrehst alles, du bringst alles durcheinander.
Er war wirklich sehr verärgert.
Er schüttelte seine goldenen Locken im Wind.
Ich kenne einen Planeten,
auf dem ein Herr mit einem roten Gesicht wohnte.
Noch nie hatte er an einer Blume gerochen.
Noch nie hatte er einen Stern gesehen.
Er hatte noch niemanden geliebt.
Nie hatte er etwas anderes getan als Rechnen.
Und jeden Tag sagte er wie du,
Ich bin ein ernsthafter Mann, ich bin ein ernsthafter Mann.
Vor lauter Stolz war er schon angeschwollen.
Aber dies ist kein Mann.
Das ist ein Pilz.
Ein, was?
Ein Schwampilz.
Der kleine Prinz schäumte jetzt vor Wut.
Seit Millionen von Jahren wachsen den Blumen Dornen.
Seit Millionen von Jahren werden diese Blumen dennoch von Schafen gefressen.
Und für dich ist es nicht wichtig, wenn man verstehen möchte,
warum sie sich so viel Mühe geben, Dornen wachsen zu lassen,
die zu nichts gut sind?
Ist der Kampf zwischen den Schafen und den Blumen etwa nicht wichtig?
Ist das nicht genauso ernsthaft und wichtig wie die Berechnungen
des aufgeblasenen roten Mannes?
Und wenn ich eine Blume kenne, die einzig ist in der Welt,
die es nirgendwo anders gibt als auf meinem Planeten.
Und wenn ein kleines Schaf eines Morgens diese Blume
mit einem einzigen Bissen vernichten kann, ohne zu wissen, was es tut,
ist das etwa nicht wichtig?
Er errötete und fuhr weiter fort.
Wenn jemand eine Blume liebt, die es nur ein einziges Mal gibt,
auf all den Millionen und Millionen Sternen,
dann macht es ihn glücklich nur, wenn er sie ansieht.
Er sagt sich, meine Blume ist nirgendwo da draußen.
Wenn das Schaf aber die Blume frisst,
dann ist das für ihn, als gingen plötzlich alle Sterne aus.
Und das soll nicht wichtig sein?
Er konnte nichts mehr sagen, denn er brach plötzlich in Tränen aus.
Es war Nacht geworden.
Ich legte meine Werkzeuge beiseite.
Mein Hammer, mein Bolzen, Durst und Tod waren mir gleichgültig.
Es war auf einem Stern, einem Planeten, meinem Planet,
auf der Erde, auf der ein kleiner Prinz getröstet werden musste.
Ich nahm ihn in die Arme, ich wiegte ihn.
Ich sagte, die Blume, die du liebst,
bist nicht in Gefahr.
Ich zeichne dir einen Maulkorb für dein Schaf.
Ich werde dir für deine Blumen einen Zaum zeichnen.
Ich ...
Ich wusste nicht, was ich weiter sagen sollte.
Ich fühlte mich äußerst verlegen.
Ich wusste nicht, wie man ihn erreichen konnte.
Es ist so geheimnisvoll, das Land der Tränen.
Ach, das Kapitel!
Bald schon lernte ich diese Blume kennen.
Es hat es schon immer auf dem Planeten des kleinen Prinzen Blumen gegeben.
Sehr einfache Blumen mit nur einem Kranz von Blütenblättern.
Sie brauchten kaum Platz und störten niemanden.
Sie erschienen eines Morgens im Gras und verschwanden am Abend wieder.
Aber diese eine hatte eines Tages Wurzeln geschlagen aus einem Samen,
der wer weiß, woher gekommen war.
Und der kleine Prinz hatte diesen kleinen Sprössling,
der ganz anders war als die anderen Sprösslinge, sehr genau beobachtet.
Es konnte eine neue Art vom Affenbootbaum sein.
Aber bald schon hörte der Strauch zu wachsen auf
und er begann, eine Blüte hervorzubringen.
Der kleine Prinz spürte,
während er die Entwicklung einer riesigen Knoss beobachtete,
dass eine wunderbare Erscheinung aus ihr hervorgehen müsse.
Aber die Blume wollte einfach nicht damit aufhören, sich vorzubereiten.
Ihre Schönheit reifte geschützt in ihrer grünen Hülle.
Sie wählte ihre Farben mit Bedacht.
Sie kleidete sich langsam an.
Sie ordnete ihre Blütenblätter eins nach dem anderen.
Sie wollte nicht so zerknittert aufgehen wie die Mondblumen.
Sie wollte nur im vollen Glanz ihrer Schönheit erscheinen.
Hey! Sie wollte hübsch sein.
Ihre geheimnisvolle Toilette dauerte Tage lang.
Und eines Morgens, gerade bei Sonnenaufgang, enthüllte sie sich.
Und sie, die mit der größten Präzision gearbeitet hatte,
gähnte und sagte,
Ah! Ich bin gerade aufgewacht.
Es tut mir leid. Ich bin noch ziemlich zerzaust.
Der kleine Prinz konnte seine Bewunderung gar nicht mehr zurückhalten.
Wie schön du bist!
Nicht wahr, erwiderte die Blume leise.
Und ich bin zur gleichen Zeit geboren, wie die Sonne.
Der kleine Prinz merkte sofort, dass sie nicht besonders bescheiden war,
aber sie war so faszinierend.
Ich glaube, es ist Zeit für das Frühstück.
Nahm sie das Gespräch wieder auf.
Hätten sie die Güte an mich zu denken?
Da errötete der kleine Prinz, holte frisches Wasser und goss die Blume.
So quälte sie ihn recht bald mit ihrer etwas zerbrechlichen Eitelkeit.
Eines Tages zum Beispiel sprach sie von ihren vier Dornen und sagte zum kleinen Prinzen,
Sie können ruhig kommen, die Tiger mit ihren Krallen.
Es gibt keine Tiger auf meinem Planeten, entgegnete der kleine Prinz,
denn Tiger fressen kein Gras.
Ich bin kein Gras, erwiderte hierauf die Blume in süßem Ton.
Verzeihen sie mir.
Vor Tigern habe ich keine Angst, aber mir graut es vor der Zugluft.
Besitzen sie nicht einen Wandschirm?
Angst vor der Zugluft?
Das ist nicht besonders glücklich für eine Pflanze, dachte der kleine Prinz.
Diese Blume ist sehr anspruchsvoll.
In der Nacht müssen sie mich schützen.
Es ist sehr kalt bei ihnen zu Hause.
Es ist nicht richtig eingestellt, da wo ich herkomme.
Da unterbrach sie sich.
Sie erschien in Form eines Samenkorns.
Sie hatte nichts von anderen Welten wissen können,
gedehmütigt, dass sie bei einer so einfachen Lüge ertappt worden war,
hustete sie zwei oder dreimal, um den kleinen Prinzen ins Unrecht zu setzen.
Der Wandschirm.
Ich wollte ihn gerade herholen, aber sie sprachen noch mit mir.
Dann zwang sie sich erneut zu einem Husten
und wollte ihm damit Gewissensbisse einreden.
Trotz seiner aufrichtigen Liebe begann der kleine Prinz bald damit an ihr zu zweifeln.
Er hatte ihre belanglosen Worte ernst genommen und war sehr unglücklich darüber geworden.
Ich hätte nicht auf sie hören sollen, erzählte er mir eines Tages.
Man sollte den Blumen nie zuhören.
Wir müssen sie betrachten und ihren Duft einatmen.
Meine Blume erfüllte meinen ganzen Planeten mit einem Duft,
aber ich wurde nicht glücklich darüber.
Diese Geschichte von den Krallen, die mich so sehr reizte, hätte mich mehr berühren sollen.
Er sagte zu mir, ich war damals nicht in der Lage das zu begreifen.
Ich hätte sie nach ihren Taten und nicht nach ihren Worten beurteilen sollen.
Sie duftete und erglüte für mich. Ich hätte niemals fortgehen dürfen.
Ich hätte hinter ihren armen kleinen Tricks ihre Zuneigung erraten sollen.
Blumen sind voller Widersprüche, aber ich war zu jung, um zu wissen, dass ich sie liebe.
Neuntes Kapitel.
Ich glaube, er benutzte für seine Flucht einen Zug wilder Vögel.
Am Morgen seiner Abreise brachte er seinen Planeten in Ordnung.
Sorgfältig reinigte er seine aktiven Vulkanen.
Er besaß zwei aktive Vulkanen.
Das war sehr praktisch fürs Kochen zum Frühstück.
Er hatte auch einen Erloschenenvulkan.
Aber er sagte sich, man kann nie wissen.
Und so fegte er auch den Erloschenenvulkan.
Wenn sie gut gefegt werden, brennen die Vulkanen sanft und gleichmäßig, ohne jemals auszubrechen.
Vulkanausbrüche sind wie Kaminfeuer.
Wir auf unserem Planeten sind ganz offensichtlich viel zu klein, um unsere Vulkanen fegen zu können.
Darum bereiten sie uns auch so viel Ärger.
Mit ein wenig Schwermut riss der kleine Prinz die letzten Triebe eines Affenbrotbaumes aus.
Er glaubte, er würde nie wieder zurückkehren.
Aber alle diese alltäglichen Arbeiten erschienen ihm an diesem Morgen ganz besonders verlockend.
Und als er die Blume zum letzten Mal goss und er sie zum Schutz unter eine Glasglocke stellte,
entdeckte er in sich den Drang zu weinen.
Lebe wohl, sagte er zu der Blume.
Aber sie antwortete nicht.
Lebe wohl, wiederholte er.
Die Blume hustete, aber es war nicht wegen ihrer Erkältung.
Ich war dumm, sagte sie schließlich.
Verzeihe mir bitte, versuche glücklich zu sein.
Es überraschte ihn, dass sie ihm keine Vorwürfe machte.
Ganz verwirrt stand er mit der Glasglocke da.
Doch diese stille Sanftmut verstand er nicht.
Ja, ich liebe dich, sagte die Blume.
Du konntest es nicht wissen, das ist meine Schuld.
Es spielt keine Rolle.
Aber du warst genauso dumm wie ich.
Versuche glücklich zu sein.
Das ist die Glaskugel, ich will sie nicht mehr.
Aber der Wind, ich bin nicht so stark erkältet,
dass die kühle Nachtluft wird mir gut tun.
Ich bin eine Blume.
Aber die Tiere, ich werde wohl zwei oder drei Raupen aushalten müssen,
um die Schmetterlinge kennenzulernen.
Das wird wohl sehr schön werden.
Wer würde mich sonst besuchen?
Du wirst weit weg sein.
Vor den großen Tieren fürchte ich mich nicht.
Ich habe meine Krallen.
Ganz einfältig zeigte sie ihre vier Dornen.
Dann fügte sie hinzu.
Mach es nicht so lang, das ist fürchterlich.
Du hast dich entschieden zu gehen, also geh.
Sie wollte nicht, dass er sie weinen sieht.
Sie war eine sehr stolze Blume.
Zehntes Kapitel.
Es war in der Nähe der Asteroiden 325, 326, 327,
328, 329 und 330.
Er begann damit, sie zu besuchen.
Er wollte sich beschäftigen und etwas lernen.
Den ersten bewohnte ein König.
Der König saß ganz in Purpur und Hermelin gekleidet,
auf einem sehr einfachen, aber majestätischen Thron.
Ah, da ist ja ein Untertan, sagte der König,
als er den kleinen Prinzen zu Gesicht bekam.
Der kleine Prinz fragte sich, wie kann er mich kennen,
wie er mich noch nie gesehen hat.
Er wusste nicht, dass die Welt für die Könige sehr einfach ist
und alle Menschen Untertanen für sie sind.
Komm, näher, dass ich dich besser sehen kann,
sagte der König stolz darauf,
dass er für jemanden König sein konnte.
Der kleine Prinz sah sich nach einem Sitzplatz um,
und der ganze Planet wurde von einem herrlichen Hermelin-Mantel bedeckt.
So blieb er stehen und weil er müde war, gähnte er.
Es ist ein grober Verstoß gegen die Etikette,
in der Gegenwart eines Königs zu gähnen, sagte der Monarch.
Ich verbiete es dir.
Ich kann aber nicht anders entgegnete der kleine Prinz ganz verwirrt.
Er hatte eine lange Reise, und ich habe nicht geschlafen.
Ich befehle dir zu gähnen, sagte da der König.
Seit Jahren habe ich niemanden gähnen sehen.
Gähnen ist eine Rarität für mich. Mach schon.
Gähne noch einmal. Das ist ein Befehl.
Das macht mir Angst, ich kann nicht, sagte der kleine Prinz,
und wurde rot.
Humhum, er widerte der König.
Dann sei es.
Ich befehle dir bald zu gähnen, und manchmal
ermurmelte ein bisschen und schien verärgert zu sein,
denn der König war in hohem Maße darauf bedacht,
daß seine Autorität respektiert würde.
Er duldete keinen Ungehorsam.
Er war ein absoluter Monarch.
Aber er war sehr gütig und gab vernünftige Befehle.
Wenn ich befehle, sagte er gewöhnlich,
wenn ich einem Generalbefehle, sich in einen Seevogel zu verwandeln
und wenn der General nicht gehorcht,
wäre es nicht die Schuld des Generals, es wäre meine Schuld.
Darf ich mich setzen, fragte der kleine Prinz zackhaft.
Ich befehle dir dies zu tun, antwortete der König
und zog majestätisch eine Falte seines Hermelin-Mantels an sich heran.
Der kleine Prinz aber staunte.
Der Planet war winzig.
Was konnte der König wohl hierauf beherrschen?
Majestät, sagte er, entschuldigt mich, daß ich euch frage.
Ich befehle dir mich zu fragen, warf der König schnell ein.
Majestät, über was herrscht ihr?
Über alles, sagte der König mit großer Klarheit.
Über alles?
Der König machte eine bedeutsame Geste auf seinen eigenen Planeten,
auf andere Planeten und auf die Sterne.
Über dies alles, fragte der kleine Prinz.
Über dies alles, antwortete der König.
Denn er war nicht nur ein absoluter Monarch,
er war auch ein universeller Monarch.
Und die Sterne gehorchen euch?
Natürlich, sagte der König, sie gehorchen sofort.
Ich toleriere keinen Ungehorsam.
Solche Macht erstaunte den kleinen Prinzen sehr.
Wenn er solche Macht gehabt hätte,
wäre er in der Lage nicht 44,
sondern gleich 72 oder sogar 100
oder selbst 200 Sonnenuntergänge
an einem Tag zu erleben,
ohne jemals seinen Stuhl dabei zu verrücken.
Und so machte ihn die Erinnerung
an seinen kleinen verlassenen Planeten ein bisschen traurig.
Und in dieser Stimmung fühlte er sich ermutigt,
den König um Gnade zu bitten.
Ich möchte so gern einen Sonnenuntergang sehen.
Tut mir bitte einen Gefallen,
befeelt der Sonne unterzugehen.
Wenn ich einem General befehle,
von einer Blume zu anderen wie ein Schmetterling zu fliegen
oder eine Tragödie zu schreiben
oder sich in einen Seevogel zu verwandeln
und wenn der General den Befehl nicht ausführt,
wäre Trüge daran die Schuld.
Er oder ich.
Das würdet ihr sein, sagte der kleine Prinz entschlossen.
Richtig, wir müssen von jedem fordern,
was er leisten kann, sagte der König.
Autorität beruht in erster Linie auf der Vernunft.
Wenn du deinen Leuten befielst, sich ins Meer zu stürzen,
werden sie sich auflehnen.
Ich habe das Recht gehorsam zu fordern,
weil meine Befehle vernünftig sind.
Was wird also mit meinem Sonnenuntergang,
erinnerte der kleine Prinz,
der niemals eine Frage vergas,
wenn er sie einmal gefragt hatte.
Du sollst deinen Sonnenuntergang haben,
ich werde ihn gebieten,
aber ich werde in meiner Gelehrsamkeit als Herrscher warten,
bis die Voraussetzungen hierfür günstig sind.
Wann wird dies der Fall sein,
wollte der kleine Prinz wissen.
Hem, hem, antwortete der König
und studierte dabei einen großen Kalender.
Hem, hem, das wird sein, etwa.
Es wird heute Abend etwa zwanzig vor acht sein.
Dann kannst du sehen, wie mir gehorcht wird.
Der kleine Prinz gähnte.
Es tat ihm Leid um den versäumten Sonnenuntergang
und er langweilte sich schon ein wenig.
Ich habe nichts mehr zu tun her, sagte er dem König.
Ich reise ab.
Bleibe, sagte der König,
der stolz darauf war, einen Untertanen zu haben.
Gehe nicht, ich mache dich zum Minister.
Minister für was?
Der, der Gerechtigkeit.
Aber es ist niemand hier, über den man richten könnte.
Das wissen wir nicht, entgegnete der König.
Ich habe noch nie eine Reise durch mein König reich gemacht.
Ich bin sehr alt.
Ich habe keinen Platz für eine Kutsche.
Und gehen, macht mich müde.
Oh, aber ich habe schon nachgesehen, sagte der kleine Prinz
und drehte sich um,
um noch einen weiteren Blick auf die andere Seite des Planeten zu werfen.
Es ist niemand da drüben.
Du musst also über dich selbst richten, antwortete der König.
Das ist das Schwerste.
Es ist viel schwerer, über sich selbst zu richten,
als über andere zu urteilen.
Wenn du es schaffst, über dich selbst gerecht zu werden,
dann bist du ein wahrer Weiser.
Ich, sagte der kleine Prinz, ich kann über mich richten,
egal wo ich mich befinde.
Ich muss nicht hier bleiben.
Hem, hem, sagte der König.
Ich glaube, auf meinem Planeten gibt es irgendwo eine Ratte.
Ich höre sie in der Nacht.
Du könntest über diese alte Ratte richten.
Du kannst sie von Zeit zu Zeit zum Tode verurteilen.
Du wird ihr Leben von deiner Gerechtigkeit abhängig.
Aber du wirst sie jedes Mal begnadigen müssen,
damit sie erhalten bleibt.
Es gibt nur eine.
Ich, antwortete der kleine Prinz, ich möchte niemanden zum Tode verurteilen
und ich glaube, ich gehe jetzt.
Nein, sagte der König.
Der kleine Prinz hatte seine Vorkehrungen bereits getroffen,
doch er wollte dem alten Monarchen nicht wehtun.
Wenn eure Majestät wert auf pünktlichen Gehorsam legen,
könntet ihr einen vernünftigen Befehl erteilen.
Ihr könntet mir zum Beispiel befehlen,
dass ich euch in einer Minute verlassen soll.
Mir scheint, dass die Bedingungen hierfür günstig sind.
Der König schwieg und der kleine Prinz zögerte zunächst,
dann brach er mit einem Seufze auf.
Ich mache dich zu meinem Gesandten, rief der König im Eilich nach.
So warte er sich einen großen Anschein von Autorität.
Die großen Leute sind sehr sonderbar,
dachte der kleine Prinz auf seiner Reise.
Elftes Kapitel.
Den zweiten Planeten bewohnte ein Eitler.
Ah, ah, es kommt Besuch von einem Bewunderer.
Rief dieser schon weit entfernt, als er den kleinen Prinzen erblickte.
Denn für die Eitlen sind die anderen Leute Bewunderer.
Guten Tag, sagte der kleine Prinz.
Sie haben einen lustigen Hut.
Er ist zum Größen, entgegnete der Eitle.
Er ist zum Größen, wenn mir die Leute beifall sollen.
Doch leider kommt hier niemand vorbei.
Wirklich, sagte der kleine Prinz, der nichts davon verstand.
Klatschte mit deinen Händen, riet ihm der eingebildete.
Der kleine Prinz klatschte seine Hände gegeneinander.
Der Eitle grüßte Bescheiden mit gesenktem Haupt
und zog seinen Hut.
Das ist unterhaltsamer, als mein Besuch beim König dachte sich der kleine Prinz.
Und so klatschte er erneut in seine Hände.
Der Eitle zog wieder seinen Hut zum Gruß.
Nach fünf Minuten dieser Übung
wurde dem kleinen Prinzen dieses monotone Spiel aber leidig.
Und damit der Hut fällt, fragte er, was muss man dafür tun?
Aber der Eitle überhörte ihn.
Eingebildete Menschen wollen immer nur Lobreden hören.
Bewunderst du mich wirklich sehr, fragte er den kleinen Prinzen.
Was bedeutet bewundern?
Bewundern heißt erkennen, dass ich der beste Mann,
der am besten gekleidete, der Reichste und Intelligenteste auf der Welt bin.
Aber du bist doch allein auf deinem Planeten?
Mach mir bitte die Freude und bewundere mich irgendwie.
Ich bewundere dich, sagte der kleine Prinz
und zuckte leicht mit den Schultern.
Aber warum ist dir das so wichtig?
Da verschwand der kleine Prinz.
Die großen Leute sind wirklich sehr sonderbar,
sagte er sich auf seiner Reise.
Zwölf des Kapitel.
Der nächste Planet wurde von einem Säufer bewohnt.
Sein Besuch war nur sehr kurz,
doch versenkte er den kleinen Prinzen in eine tiefe Traurigkeit.
Was machst du hier?
sprach er zu dem Säufer, den er stumm sitzend
vor einer Reihe Lehrer und einer Reihe voller Flaschen vorfand.
Ich trinke, antwortete der Säufer mit düsterer Miene.
Und warum trinkst du? fragte der kleine Prinz.
Um zu vergessen, sagte der Säufer.
Was willst du vergessen? fragte der kleine Prinz,
dem der Säufer schon Leid tat.
Ich will vergessen, dass ich mich schäme,
gestand der Säufer und ließ den Kopf hängen.
Über was schämst du dich? fragte der kleine Prinz,
beharlich weiter, denn er wollte ihm helfen.
Ich schäme mich, weil ich saufe,
sagte der Säufer abschließend und hüllte sich in tiefes Schweigen.
Da verschwand der kleine Prinz bestürzt.
Die großen Leute sind wirklich sehr, sehr sonderbar.
Dachte er sich, während er weiterreiste.
Dreizehntes Kapitel.
Der vierte Planet war der eines Geschäftsmannes.
Dieser Mann war so beschäftigt,
dass er nicht einmal aufsah, als der kleine Prinz eintraf.
Guten Tag, sagte der kleine Prinz.
Ihre Zigarette ist ausgegangen.
3 plus 2 ist 5.
5 plus 7 ist 12.
12 plus 3 ist 15.
Guten Tag, 15 plus 7 ist 22.
22 plus 6 ist 28.
Keine Zeit, sie wieder anzuzünden.
26 plus 5 ist 31.
Puh, das macht also 501 Millionen.
622.731.
500 Millionen, was?
Was, du bist noch da?
501 Millionen, ich habe es vergessen.
Ich habe so viel Arbeit.
Ich meine es ernst, mit Kindereien kann ich mich nicht abgeben.
2 plus 5 ist 7.
501 Millionen, was?
Wiederholte der kleine Prinz,
der noch niemals in seinem Leben eine Frage vergessen hatte,
die er bereits gefragt hatte.
Da hob der Geschäftsmann seinen Kopf.
Seit 54 Jahren lebe ich nun auf diesem Planeten
und bin in dieser Zeit nur dreimal gestört worden.
Das erste Mal war es vor 22 Jahren ein Käfer,
der von, wer weiß, woher geflogen kam.
Er machte einen fürchterlichen Lärm
und ich machte vier Fehler bei meiner Berechnung.
Das zweite Mal, es war vor elf Jahren,
hatte ich einen Anfall von Rheumatismus.
Ich konnte mich nicht mehr bewegen.
Mir fehlte die Zeit zum Herumbummeln.
Ich bin ein ernsthafter Mensch, bin ich.
Das dritte Mal ist jetzt.
Ich sagte 501 Millionen.
Millionen von was?
Der Geschäftsmann begriff,
dass er keine Hoffnung auf seinen Frieden hatte.
Millionen von diesen kleinen Dingern,
die wir manchmal am Himmel sehen.
Fliegen? Nein, die kleinen Dinger, die glänzen.
Bienen? Natürlich nicht.
Kleine goldene Dinger, die die faulen Tag träumend machen.
Aber ich bin ein ernsthafter Mensch, bin ich.
Ich habe keine Zeit zum Träumen.
Ah, die Sterne, korrekt, Sterne.
Und was willst du mit diesen 500 Millionen Sternen?
501 Millionen, 622.731.
Ich bin ein ernsthafter Mensch, ich bin äußerst genau.
Und was willst du mit diesen Sternen tun?
Was ich damit tun kann? Ja.
Nichts, ich besitze sie.
Du besitzt die Sterne? Ja, natürlich.
Aber ich kenne einen König, der?
Könige besitzen nichts.
Sie herrschen über, das ist etwas ganz anderes.
Und was nützt es dir, die Sterne zu besitzen?
Sie machen mich reich.
Und was nützt dir dieser Reichtum?
Ich kann andere Sterne kaufen, wenn sie gefunden werden.
Er ist ein bisschen wie der Säufer, dachte sich der kleine Prinz.
Er hatte aber noch lange nicht alle Fragen gefragt.
Wie kann man die Sterne besitzen?
Wem gehören sie denn? Er widerte der Geschäftsmann mürrisch.
Ich weiß nicht einer Person.
Wem gehören sie mir, denn ich dachte als erster daran.
Das reicht? Und ob?
Wenn du einen Diamanten findest, der niemandem gehört, gehört er dir.
Wenn du eine Insel entdeckst, die niemandem gehört, dann gehört sie dir.
Wenn du eine Idee zuerst hattest, und du patentierst sie, dann gehört sie dir.
Ich besitze die Sterne, denn niemand vor mir hatte jemals daran gedacht, sie zu besitzen.
Das ist wahr, sagte der kleine Prinz.
Und was stellst du damit an?
Ich verwalte, ich zähle sie und zähle sie immer wieder, sagte der Geschäftsmann.
Das ist sehr schwierig, aber ich bin ein sehr ernsthafter Mann.
Der kleine Prinz war immer noch nicht zufrieden.
Wenn ich einen Seidenschal besitze, kann ich ihn mir um den Hals binden und mit mir nehmen.
Wenn ich eine Blume sehe und sie pflücke, dann kann ich sie mitnehmen.
Aber Sterne kann man nicht pflücken.
Nein, aber ich kann sie in eine Bank legen.
Was bedeutet das?
Es bedeutet, dass ich die Anzahl meiner Sterne auf ein Stück Papierschreibe
und dann verschließ ich dieses Papier mit einem Schlüssel in der Schublade.
Das ist alles, das ist genug.
Das ist lustig, dachte der kleine Prinz.
Das ist fast sogar poetisch, aber ernst ist es nicht.
Der kleine Prinz hatte von ernsthaften Dingen ganz andere Vorstellungen als die Idee der großen Leute.
Ich, sagte er noch einmal, ich besitze eine Blume, die ich jeden Tag gieße.
Ich besitze drei Vulkanen und jede Woche kehre ich sie.
Ich kehre sogar den erloschenen Vulkanen, man kann nie wissen.
Es ist gut für meine Vulkanen und es ist auch gut für meine Blume, dass ich sie besitze.
Aber du nützt den Sternen gar nichts.
Da riss der Geschäftsmann den Mund auf, aber er fand keine Antwort und der kleine Prinz verschwand.
Die großen Leute sind tatsächlich sehr sonderbar, sagte er sich auf seiner Reise.
Vierzehntes Kapitel.
Der fünfte Planet war auch sehr sonderbar.
Es war der kleinste Planet von allen.
Er hatte gerade genug Platz für eine Straßenlaterne und einen Laternenanzünder.
Der kleine Prinz konnte sich gar nicht erklären, wozu man irgendwo im Himmel auf einem Planeten ohne einem Haus
und sogar ohne Bevölkerung eine Straßenlaterne und einen Laternenanzünder benötigt.
Doch er dachte sich, vielleicht ist dieser Mann verrückt.
Er wäre jedoch weniger verrückt als der König, der Eitel, der Geschäftsmann und der Seufer.
Seine Arbeit jedenfalls macht Sinn.
Wenn er seine Laterneanzündet, ist es, als ob er eine neuen Sternerschaft oder eine Blume.
Wenn er seine Laterne löscht, wiegt er Blume oder Stern in den Schlaf.
Das ist ein schöner Beruf.
Das ist wirklich sehr nützlich, weil es schön ist.
Als er auf dem Planeten ankam, grüßte er den Laternenanzünder respektvoll.
Guten Tag, warum hast du gerade deine Lampe ausgelöscht?
Das ist eine Anordnung, sagte der Laternenanzünder.
Guten Morgen.
Was bedeutet das?
Es bedeutet, meine Lampe auszulöschen.
Guten Abend.
Da zündete er sie wieder an.
Und warum hast du sie wieder angezündet?
Das ist eine Anordnung, sagte der Laternenanzünder erneut.
Das verstehe ich nicht, meinte der kleine Prinz.
Das ist einfach erklärt, sagte der Anzünder.
Eine Anordnung ist eine Anordnung.
Guten Morgen.
Und schon löschte er seine Lampe wieder aus.
Danach wischte er sich seine Stirn mit einem roten Taschentuch.
Ich habe eine schreckliche Arbeit.
Sie war einmal sehr vernünftig.
Ich zündete am Morgen die Lampe an und löschte sie am Abend.
Den Rest des Tages hatte ich frei und den Rest der Nacht konnte ich schlafen.
Was hat sich seit dieser Zeit an der Anordnung verändert?
Die Anordnung hat sich verändert, sagte der Anzünder.
Das ist ja die Tragödie.
Der Planet hat sich von Jahr zu Jahr schneller und schneller gedreht.
Und die Anordnung ist so geblieben.
Und fragte der kleine Prinz.
Und jetzt macht er in jeder Minute eine Umdrehung.
Ich komme nicht eine Sekunde zur Ruhe.
Ich dreh und wende mich einmal in jeder Minute.
Das ist lustig.
Ein Tag dauert bei dir eine Minute.
Das ist nicht lustig, meinte der Laternanzünder.
Seit wir miteinander sprechen, ist ein Monat vergangen.
Ein Monat? Ja doch.
30 Minuten, 30 Tage, guten Abend.
Und schon zündete er wieder seine Laterne an.
Der kleine Prinz sah ihm bei der Arbeit zu.
Er mochte diesen Laternanzünder, der so brav seine Anordnungen ausführte.
Er erinnerte sich an die Sonnenuntergänge, die er selbst einmal verfolgte,
indem er seinen Stuhl nachzog.
Er wollte seinem Freund helfen.
Weißt du, ich kenne einen Weg, wie du dich ausruhen kannst, wann immer du willst.
Ich will immer, sagte der Laternanzünder.
Denn man kann sowohl treu und faul zugleich sein, der kleine Prinz vorfort.
Dein Planet ist so winzig, dass du mit drei Schritten herum bist.
Du musst nur langsam genug gehen, um immer in der Sonne zu bleiben.
Wenn du dich ausruhen willst, dann gehst du einfach.
Und der Tag dauert so lange, wie du möchtest.
Das ist nicht besonders schlau, sagte der Anzünder, denn ich liebe den Schlaf.
Dann ist es zwecklos, sagte der kleine Prinz.
Es ist zwecklos, sagte der Anzünder, guten Morgen.
Da löschte er schon wieder seine Lampe aus.
Dieser Jena, sagte der kleine Prinz, während er seine Reise fortsetzte,
würde von allen anderen verachtet werden,
vom König, vom Eidlen, vom Seufer und vom Geschäftsmann.
Aber er ist der Einzige, der mir nichts lächerlich erscheint.
Es ist vielleicht, weil er nur an andere Dinge denkt als an sich selbst.
Er stieß einen Seufzer des Bedauerns aus und dachte noch,
dieser Jena wäre der Einzige, den ich zu meinem Freund gemacht hätte.
Doch sein Planet ist wirklich sehr klein.
Er gibt es keinen Platz für zwei.
Was sich der kleine Prinz nicht einzugestehen, wagte war,
dass er diesem gesegneten Planeten nachweinte,
vor allem wegen der 1.440 Sonnenuntergänge in 24 Stunden.
15. Kapitel.
Der sechste Planet war zehnmal größer.
ihn bewohnte ein alter Mann, der gewaltige Bücher schrieb.
Die Ann, da kommt ein Entdecker, sagte er, als er den kleinen Prinzen zu Gesicht bekam.
Der kleine Prinz setzte sich auf einen Tisch und ruhte sich ein wenig aus.
Er war schon so viel gereist.
Wo kommst du her, wollte der alte Mann wissen?
Was ist das für ein dickes Buch, sagte der kleine Prinz?
Was machen Sie hier?
Ich bin ein Geograph, sagte der alte Mann.
Was ist ein Geograph?
Das ist ein Gelerter, der alle mehrere Flüsse, Städte, Berge und Wüsten kennt.
Das ist sehr interessant, sagte der kleine Prinz.
Das ist endlich ein echter Beruf.
Er warf einen Blick auf den Planeten des Geografen.
Noch nie hatte er einen so majestätischen Planeten gesehen.
Er ist sehr schön ihr Planet.
Gibt es hier auch Ozeane?
Das weiß ich nicht, sagte der Geograph.
Ah, der kleine Prinz war enttäuscht.
Und Berge?
Auch das kann ich nicht wissen, sagte der Geograph.
Und Städte und Flüsse und Wüsten?
Kann ich auch nicht, sagte der Geograph.
Aber Sie sind doch ein Geograph.
Das ist richtig, sagte der Geograph.
Aber ich bin kein Entdecker.
Mir fehlt es ganz an Entdeckern.
Nicht der Geograph geht die Städte, Flüsse, Seen, Meere und Wüsten zählen.
Der Geograph ist so wichtig, um durch die Welt zu streifen.
Er verlässt sein Büro nie.
Aber er empfängt die Entdecker.
Er befragt sie und notiert sich ihre Erinnerungen.
Und wenn ihm ihre Erinnerungen bedeutungsvoll erscheinen,
stellt der Geograph eine Untersuchung
über den Charakter des Entdeckers an.
Warum?
Weil ein Entdecker der lügt.
Eine Katastrophe über die Geografiebücher
hereinbrechen lassen würde,
ebenso wie ein Entdecker, der zu viel trinkt.
Warum? fragte der kleine Prinz.
Weil soll verdoppelt sehen.
Der Geograph würde zwei Berge vermerken, wo es nur einen gab.
Ich kenne jemanden, sagte der kleine Prinz.
Der würde ein schlechter Entdecker sein.
Das ist möglich.
Wenn sich aber der Charakter eines Entdeckers als gut herausstellt,
dann macht man eine Untersuchung über seine Entdeckung.
Wird man nachsehen?
Nein, das wäre zu kompliziert.
Aber von einem Entdecker erwartet man,
dass er Beweise liefert.
Wenn seine Entdeckung zum Beispiel ein großer Berg ist,
fordert man, dass er große Steine vorzeigt.
Da gingen dem Geographen plötzlich die Augen auf.
Aber du kommst doch von weit her.
Du bist ein Entdecker.
Du musst mir deinen Planeten beschreiben.
Nachdem der Geograph sein Register aufgeschlagen hatte,
spitzte er seinen Bleistift.
Zunächst notierte man die Geschichten von Entdeckern
mit einem Bleistift.
Sie werden erst dann mit Tinte niedergeschrieben,
wenn der Entdecker Beweise erbracht hat.
Und fragte der Geograph.
Oh, bei mir zu Hause, sagte der kleine Prinz,
ist es nicht sehr interessant, es ist sehr klein.
Ich habe drei Vulkanen,
zwei aktive Vulkanen und einen Erlöschenen.
Aber man kann ja nie wissen.
Man kann nie wissen, sagte der Geograph.
Ich habe auch eine Blume.
Wir notieren Blume nicht, sagte der Geograph.
Wieso nicht? Sie sind das Schönste.
Weil Blumen vergänglich sind.
Was bedeutet vergänglich?
Die Geografiebücher, sagte der Geograph.
Sind die wertvollsten aller Bücher.
Sie veralten niemals.
Es ist sehr selten, dass ein Berg seine Lage verändert.
Es ist auch selten, dass ein Ozean sein Wasser entleert.
Wir notieren uns die ewigen Dinge.
Aber erloschende Vulkanen können aufwachen,
unterbrach ihn der kleine Prinz.
Was bedeutet vergänglich?
Ob Vulkanen erloschen sind oder nicht, ist für uns einerlei,
sagte der Geograph.
Worauf es uns ankommt, ist der Berg.
Er ändert sich nicht.
Aber was bedeutet vergänglich,
wiederholte der kleine Prinz,
der in seinem Leben noch nie auf eine Frage verzichtete,
die er bereits gefragt hatte.
Es bedeutet vom baldigen Verschwindem bedroht.
Ist meine Blume vom baldigen Verschwindem bedroht?
Natürlich.
Meine Blume ist vergänglich, dachte der kleine Prinz.
Und sie hat nur vier Dornen, um sich gegen die Welt zu erwehren.
Und ich ließ sie allein zu Hause zurück.
Dies war sein erstes Gefühl des Bedauerns.
Aber erfaßte Mut.
Was raten Sie mir?
Was soll ich besuchen?
fragte er.
Den Planeten Erde, antwortete der Geograph.
Er hat einen guten Ruf.
Und der kleine Prinz ging fort
und dachte an seine Blume.
Sechzehntes Kapitel.
Der siebte Planet war also die Erde.
Die Erde ist kein gewöhnlicher Planet.
Es gibt dort 111 Könige.
Nicht zu vergessen sind die Könige in Afrika 7000 Geographen,
900.000 Geschäftsleute, 7.5 Millionen Seufer, 311 Millionen Eitle,
alles in allem rund 2 Milliarden Erwachsene.
Um Euch eine Vorstellung von der Größe der Erde zu geben,
will ich Euch sagen, dass es vor der Entdeckung der Elektrizität
notwendig war, eine regelrechte Armee von 462.511 Laternenanzündern
auf allen sechs Kontinenten zu beschäftigen.
Aus der Ferne betrachtet hatte dies einen wunderbaren Effekt.
Die Bewegungen dieser Armee wurden organisiert wie die eines Opernballetts.
Zuerst kamen die Laternanzünder aus Neuseeland und Australien.
Nachdem sie ihre Lampen angezündet hatten, gingen sie schlafen.
Die nächsten Tanzschrötte vollbrachten die Laternanzünder aus China und Sibirien.
Auch sie wurden hinter die Kulissen gewinnt.
Danach waren die Laternanzünder Russlands und Indiens an der Reihe,
dann die aus Afrika und Europa, dann die aus Südamerika,
dann die aus Nordamerika und sie irden sich noch niemals in der Reihenfolge ihres Auftretens.
Das war großartig.
Nur der Anzünder der einzigen Laterne am Nordpol
und sein Kollege von der einzigen Laterne am Südpol
führten erleben voller Müßiggang und Wohlbehagen.
Sie arbeiteten gerade zweimal im Jahr, siebzehntes Kapitel.
Wenn man schlau erscheinen will, kommt man manchmal ins Pralen.
Ich war nicht ganz ehrlich, als ich euch von den Laternanzündern erzählte.
Ich könnte all jenen, die unseren Planeten nicht kennen, eine falsche Vorstellung von ihm geben.
Die Menschen brauchen nur sehr wenig Platz auf der Erde.
Wenn die zwei Milliarden Menschen, die auf der Erde leben, sich ein wenig zusammengedrängt aufstellen würden,
eben wie bei einem Volksfest, dann könnten sie leicht auf einem öffentlichen Platz
von 20 Meilen Länge und 20 Meilen Breite unterkommen.
Man könnte die ganze Menschheit auf der kleinsten Insel im Pazifik zusammendrängen.
Die großen Leute werden dies natürlich nicht glauben, sie bilden sich ein, dass sie viel Platz benötigen.
Sie nehmen sich so wichtig wie Affenbrotbäume.
Man sollte ihnen raten, Dieselberechnung zu tun.
Sie vergöttern die Zahlen, das würde ihnen gefallen.
Aber ihr sollt eure Zeit nicht mit dieser Aufgabe verschwenden.
Es ist sinnlos, vertraut mir.
Als der kleine Prinz auf die Erde kam, war er überrascht, niemanden zu Gesicht zu bekommen.
Er hatte schon Angst, auf dem falschen Planeten gelandet zu sein,
als sich ein Ring in der Farbe des Mondes über den Sand schlängelte.
Guten Abend, sagte der kleine Prinz höflich.
Guten Abend, sagte die Schlange.
Auf welchen Planeten bin ich gefallen, fragte der kleine Prinz.
Auf die Erde in Afrika, sagte die Schlange.
Oh, gibt es keine Menschen auf der Erde?
Hier ist die Wüste.
Es gibt keine Menschen in der Wüste.
Die Erde ist groß, sagte die Schlange.
Der kleine Prinz setzte sich auf einen Felsen und blickte zum Himmel.
Ich frage mich, sagte er, ob die Sterne leuchten, damit jeder seinen eigenen eines Tages wiederfindet.
Sieh dir meinen Planeten an, er steht direkt über uns.
Aber er ist weit weg.
Er ist schön, sagte die Schlange.
Was machst du hier?
Ich habe Schwierigkeiten mit einer Blume, sagte der kleine Prinz.
Ah, sagte die Schlange.
Und sie schwiegen.
Wo sind die Menschen?
Durchbrach schließlich der kleine Prinz das Schweigen.
Es ist einsam in der Wüste.
Es ist auch bei den Menschen einsam, sagte die Schlange.
Der kleine Prinz betrachtete sie eine lange Zeit.
Du bist ein lustiges Tier, sagte er schließlich, so dick wie ein Finger.
Aber ich bin mächtiger als der Finger eines Königs, sagte die Schlange.
Der kleine Prinz lächelte.
Du bist nicht besonders mächtig, du hast noch nicht einmal Beine.
Du kannst nicht einmal reisen.
Ich kann dich weiterbringen als ein Schiff, sagte die Schlange.
Sie wickelte sich um den Knöchel des kleinen Prinzen wie ein goldenes Armband.
Wen auch immer ich berühre, den schicke ich zu der Erde zurück aus der Erkam, sagte sie noch.
Aber du bist rein, du kommst von einem Stern.
Der kleine Prinz antwortete nicht.
Du tust mir leid auf dieser Erde aus Granit, weil du so schwach bist.
Ich kann dir eines Tages helfen, wenn du dich nach deinem Planeten zurücksehst.
Ich kann, oh, ich habe sehr gut verstanden, sagte der kleine Prinz, aber warum sprichst du immer in Rätseln?
Ich löse sie alle, sagte die Schlange, und sie schwiegen.
18. Kapitel
Der kleine Prinz durchquerte die Wüste und begegnete nur einer Blume.
Eine Blume mit drei Blütenblättern, eine recht karge Blume.
Guten Tag, sagte der kleine Prinz.
Guten Tag, sagte die Blume.
Bitte, wo sind die Menschen, fragte der kleine Prinz höflich.
Die Blume sah eines Tages eine Karavane vorüberziehen.
Die Menschen, es gibt, glaube ich, sechs oder sieben.
Ich sah sie vor einigen Jahren, aber man weiß nie, wo man sie finden kann.
Der Wind verwet sie, sie haben keine Wurzeln, das stört sie sehr.
Auf Wiedersehen, sagte der kleine Prinz.
Auf Wiedersehen, sagte die Blume.
19. Kapitel
Der kleine Prinz stieg auf ein hohen Berg.
Die einzigen Berge, die er kannte, waren die drei Vulkanen, die ihm nur bis zu den Knien reichten.
Und den erloschenen Vulkan benutzte er als Schemel.
Von einem Berg so hoch wie diesem dachte er, kann ich in einem Augenblick den ganzen Planeten und die ganze Menschheit überschauen.
Aber er sah nichts weiter als die Nadeln, spitzer Felsen.
Guten Tag, sagte er höflich.
Guten Tag, guten Tag, guten Tag, antwortete das Echo.
Wer bist du? fragte der kleine Prinz.
Wer bist du? Wer bist du? Wer bist du? antwortete das Echo.
Seit meine Freunde, ich bin hier allein, sagte er.
Ich bin allein, ich bin allein, ich bin allein, antwortete das Echo.
Was für ein einzigartiger Planet, dachte er sich.
Alles ist trocken, voller Spitzen und äußerst zahlt sich.
Und die Menschen haben keine Fantasie.
Sie wiederholen, was man ihnen sagt.
Zu Hause hatte ich eine Blume.
Sie war immer die Erste.
20. Kapitel
Der kleine Prinz war schon lange durch Sand, Felsen und Schnee gewandert.
Da entdeckte er endlich eine Straße.
Und alle Straßen fügen zu den Menschen.
Guten Tag, sagte er.
Es war ein Blumengarten voller Rosen.
Guten Tag, sagten die Rosen.
Der kleine Prinz betrachtete sie.
Sie sahen alle genau wie seine Blume aus.
Der Seid ihr fragten sie erstaunt.
Wir sind die Rosen, sagten die Rosen.
Ah, sagte der kleine Prinz.
Da fühlte er sich plötzlich sehr unglücklich.
Seine Blume hatte ihm erzählt, dass sie einzig wäre auf der Welt.
Und hier waren 5.000 davon in einem Garten, die sich alle glichen.
Sie würde sehr verärgert sein, sagte er.
Wenn sie ihn hier sehe, sie würde viel husten und so tun, als ob sie sterben müsse,
um sich nicht der Lächerlichkeit preiszugeben.
Und ich wäre zu behaupten gezwungen, dass ich mich um sie sorgen werde,
sonst würde sie sterben, nur um mich zu demütigen.
Dann, sagte er noch, ich dachte, ich wäre reich mit einer einzigen Blume.
Doch ich habe nur eine gewöhnliche Rose.
Sie und meine drei Vulkaner, die mir kaum bis zu meinem Knie reichen,
von denen einer vielleicht für immer erloschen ist,
das macht aus mir keinen großen Fürsten.
Er legte sich ins Gras und weinte.
21. Kapitel
Da erschien plötzlich der Fuchs.
Guten Tag, sagte der Fuchs.
Guten Tag, antwortete der kleine Prinz höflich, der sich umdrehte, aber nichts entdecken konnte.
Ich bin hier, sagte die Stimme unter einem Apfelbaum.
Wer bist du, fragte der kleine Prinz.
Du bist sehr hübsch.
Ich bin ein Fuchs, sagte der Fuchs.
Komm und spiel mit mir, schlug der kleine Prinz vor.
Ich bin so traurig.
Ich kann nicht mit dir spielen, sagte der Fuchs.
Ich bin nicht gezähmt.
Ah, Verzeihung, sagte der kleine Prinz.
Nachdem er kurz überlegt hatte, fügte er hinzu.
Was bedeutet zähmen?
Du bist nicht von hier, sagte der Fuchs.
Was führt dich her?
Ich suche die Menschen, sagte der kleine Prinz.
Was bedeutet zähmen?
Die Menschen, sagte der Fuchs.
Sie haben Waffen und sie jagen, das ist ärgerlich.
Sie halten sich auch Hühner, das ist die einzige Interesse.
Suchst du Hühner?
Nein, sagte der kleine Prinz.
Ich suche Freunde.
Was bedeutet zähmen?
Das wird oft ganz vernachlässigt, sagte der Fuchs.
Es bedeutet sich vertraut miteinander machen.
Vertraut machen?
Natürlich, sagte der Fuchs.
Du bist für mich nur ein kleiner Junge.
Ein kleiner Junge wie hunderttausend andere auch.
Ich brauche dich nicht.
Und du brauchst mich auch nicht.
Ich bin für dich ein Fuchs unter hunderttausenden von Füchsen.
Aber wenn du mich zähmst, dann werden wir einander brauchen.
Du wirst für mich einzigartig sein.
Und ich werde für dich einzigartig sein in der ganzen Welt.
Ich verstehe allmählich, sagte der kleine Prinz.
Da gibt es eine Blume.
Ich glaube, sie hat mich gezähmt.
Das ist gut möglich, sagte der Fuchs.
Auf der Erde entdecken wir alle möglichen Dinge.
Oh, das ist nicht auf der Erde, sagte der kleine Prinz.
Der Fuchs schien fasziniert davon.
Auf einem anderen Planeten?
Ja, genau.
Gibt es Jäger auf diesem Planeten?
Nein.
Das ist interessant.
Und Hühner?
Nein.
Nichts ist perfekt, säuft der Fuchs.
Aber er kam auf seine vorherige Idee zurück.
Mein Leben ist eintönig.
Ich jage Hühner, die Menschen jagen mich.
Alle Hühner gleichen einander.
Und alle Menschen sind gleich.
Das langweilt mich ein wenig.
Aber wenn du mich zähmst,
wird mein Leben heiter wie die Sonne sein.
Ich werde den Klang deiner Schritte
von anderen unterscheiden lernen.
Alle anderen Schritte jagen mich in meinen Bau.
Deine Schritte werden mich wie Musik
aus meinem Bau herauslocken.
Und dann schau.
Siehst du dort die Weizenfelder?
Ich esse kein Brot.
Weizen ist für mich ohne Nutzen.
Die Weizenfelder erinnern mich an nichts.
Und das ist traurig.
Aber du hast goldene Haare.
Wie wunderbar es sein wird,
wenn du mich gezähmt hast.
Der goldene Weizen wird mich an dich erinnern.
Und ich werde das Brausen des Windes
durch den Weizen lieben.
Da verstummte der Fuchs
und schaute den kleinen Prinzen lange an.
Bitte zähme mich, sagte er.
Das würde ich gerne tun, antwortete der kleine Prinz.
Aber ich habe nicht viel Zeit.
Ich muss Freunde finden und viele Dinge lernen.
Man versteht nur die Dinge, die man zähmt,
sagte der Fuchs.
Die Menschen haben keine Zeit mehr,
um etwas kennen zu lernen.
Sie kaufen sich alles fertig in den Geschäften.
Da es aber keine Läden für Freunde gibt,
haben die Menschen keine Freunde mehr.
Wenn du einen Freund willst, dann zähme mich.
Was muss ich machen, sagte der kleine Prinz.
Du musst sehr geduldig sein, antwortete der Fuchs.
Du wirst dich zunächst in die Nähe.
Ich habe nicht mehr Zeit,
antwortete der Fuchs.
Du wirst dich zunächst mit einem kleinen Abstand
zu mir ins Gras setzen.
Ich werde dich aus den Augenwinkeln aus anschauen
und du wirst schweigen.
Sprache ist eine große Quelle für Missverständnisse.
Aber jeden Tag setzt du dich ein wenig näher.
Am nächsten Tag kam der kleine Prinz wieder.
Es wäre besser gewesen,
wenn du zur gleichen Zeit gekommen wirst, sagte der Fuchs.
Wenn du zum Beispiel um vier Uhr am Nachmittag kommst,
dann kann ich schon um drei Uhr beginnen, glücklich zu sein.
Je mehr die Zeit voranschreitet,
umso glücklicher werde ich.
Um vier werde ich mich schon aufregen und beunruhigen.
Dann entdecke ich den Preis des Glücks.
Am vier werde ich mich schon aufregen und beunruhigen.
Aber wenn du zu irgendeiner Zeit kommst,
werde ich nie wissen, wann mein Herz bei dir sein soll.
Es muss Bräuche geben.
Was ist dein Brauch, fragte der kleine Prinz.
Das ist auch in Vergessenheit geraten, sagte der Fuchs.
Dies ist etwas, das einen Tag vom anderen unterscheidet,
eine Stunde von der anderen Stunde.
Bei meinen Jägern zum Beispiel
gibt es einen Brauch.
Donnerstags tanzen sie mit den Mädchen des Dorfes.
Donnerstag ist daher ein wunderbarer Tag.
Denn dann werde ich mich bis zum Weinberg wagen.
Wenn die Jäger irgendwann zum Tanz gehen würden,
wäre jeder Tag gleich und ich hätte niemals Ferien.
So also wurde der kleine Prinz mit dem Fuchs.
Dann hatte ich mich bis zum Weinberg wagen.
Wenn die Jäger irgendwann zum Tanz gehen würden,
so also wurde der kleine Prinz mit dem Fuchs vertraut.
Und als die Stunde des Abschieds nahe war,
ach, sagte der Fuchs, ich muss weinen.
Du bist selbst daran schuld, sagte der kleine Prinz,
ich wünsche mir nicht, dass es dir schlecht geht,
aber du wolltest von mir, dass ich dich zähme.
So ist es, sagte der Fuchs.
Aber nun musst du weinen, sagte der kleine Prinz,
ich wünsche mir nicht, dass es dir schlecht geht,
aber nun musst du weinen, sagte der kleine Prinz.
So ist es, sagte der Fuchs.
So hast du nichts gewonnen.
Ich habe die Farbe des Weitzens gewonnen, sagte der Fuchs.
Dann fügte er hinzu.
Geh und zieh dir die Rosen wieder an.
Du wirst verstehen, dass deine Rose einzigartig ist.
Du wirst zu mir zurückkommen und mir lebwohl sagen.
Und ich werde dir ein Geheimnis verharten.
Der kleine Prinz ging wieder zu den Rosen.
Ihr seid nicht wie meine Rose, noch seid ihr nichts, sagte er.
Niemand hat sich mit euch vertraut gemacht
und ihr habt euch niemandem vertraut gemacht.
Ihr seid wie mir mein Fuchs zuvor gewesen war.
Er war nur ein Fuchs wie hunderttausend andere,
aber ich habe ihn zu meinem Freund gemacht
und jetzt ist er einzigartig in der Welt.
Das beschämte die Rosen sehr.
Ihr seid schön, aber ihr seid leer, sagte er noch.
Für euch kann man nicht sterben.
Natürlich könnte irgendein Passant,
der meine Rose zu Gesicht bekommt, glauben,
dass sie wie ihr wäre.
Aber in sich ist sie wichtiger als ihr alle,
denn sie ist es, die ich gegossen habe.
Sie ist es, die ich unter eine Glasglocke gestellt habe.
Sie ist es, die ich mit einem Wandschirm geschützt habe.
Sie ist es, deren Raupen ich getötet habe.
Mit Ausnahme von zwei oder drei der Schmitterlinge wegen.
Und sie ist es auch, der ich zugehört habe,
wie sie sich beklagte oder pralte,
oder auch manchmal schwieg,
denn sie ist meine Rose.
Dann ging er zum Fuchs zurück.
Lebe wohl, sagte er.
Lebe wohl, sagte der Fuchs.
Hier ist mein Geheimnis.
Es ist sehr einfach.
Man sieht nur mit dem Herzen gut.
Das Wesentliche ist für die Augen unsichtbar.
Wiederholte der kleine Prinz, um es sich einzuprägen.
Die Zeit, die du für deine Rose gegeben hast,
sie macht deine Rose so wichtig.
Die Zeit, die ich für meine Rose gegeben habe,
sagte der kleine Prinz, um es sich einzuprägen.
Die Menschen haben diese Wahrheit vergessen,
sagte der Fuchs.
Aber du darfst sie nicht vergessen.
Du bist für das verantwortlich,
was du dir vertraut gemacht hast.
Du bist für deine Rose verantwortlich.
Ich bin für meine Rose verantwortlich.
Wiederholte der kleine Prinz, um sich auch dies einzuprägen.
22. Kapitel
Guten Tag, sagte der kleine Prinz.
Guten Tag, sagte der Weichensteller.
Was machst du hier, sagte der kleine Prinz?
Ich sortiere die reisenden Tausenderweise,
sagte der Weichensteller.
Die Züge, in denen sie reisen, schicke ich mal nach rechts, mal nach links.
Und ein grelleuchtener Schnellzug,
grollend wie ein Donnern, erschütterte das Stellwerk.
Sie sind in Eile, sagte der kleine Prinz.
Was suchen Sie?
Der Lokführer weiß es selbst nicht, sagte der Weichensteller.
Da donnerte ein zweiter grelleuchtener Schnellzug
in der anderen Richtung vorbei.
Sind Sie schon zurück, sagte der kleine Prinz.
Das sind nicht die gleichen, sagte der Weichensteller.
Sie sind andere.
Waren Sie nicht zufrieden, wo Sie waren?
Wir sind nie zufrieden, wo wir sind, sagte der Weichensteller.
Und es donnerte ein dritter strahlender Schnellzug vorbei.
Verfolgen Sie die ersten reisenden, sagte der kleine Prinz.
Sie verfolgen gar nichts, sagte der Weichensteller.
Sie schlafen in ihm oder sie gähnen nur.
Nur die Kinder drücken ihre Nasen an die Fenster.
Nur die Kinder wissen, was sie wollen, sagte der kleine Prinz.
Sie verbringen ihre Zeit mit einer Puppe
und sie wird ihnen sehr wichtig.
Und wenn man sie ihnen wegnimmt, weinen sie.
Sie haben Glück, sagte der Weichensteller.
23. Kapitel.
Guten Tag, sagte der kleine Prinz.
Guten Tag, sagte der Händler.
Er war ein Händler, der durststillende Pillen verkaufte.
Man schluckt eine Pille pro Woche und hat kein Bedürfnis mehr zu trinken.
Warum verkaufst du das, sagte der kleine Prinz.
Das bringt eine große Zeit Ersparnis, sagte der Händler.
Experten haben dies berechnet.
Man kann dreiundfünfzig Minuten pro Woche einsparen.
Und was macht man mit diesen dreiundfünfzig Minuten?
Man macht damit, was man will.
Ich würde, sagte der kleine Prinz,
wenn ich mir dreiundfünfzig Minuten erspart hätte,
gemütlich zu einem Brunnen gehen.
24. Kapitel.
Es war am achten Tag nach meinem Unfall in der Wüste,
als ich die Geschichte von dem Händler hörte
und meinen letzten Tropfen meines Wasservorrats trank.
Ah, sagte ich zum kleinen Prinzen.
Deine Erinnerungen sind sehr hübsch,
aber mein Flugzeug ist noch nicht repariert.
Ich habe nichts mehr zu trinken,
und ich wäre sehr glücklich darüber,
wenn ich ganz gemächtlich zu einem Brunnen gehen könnte.
Mein Freund der Fuchs, sagte er zu mir.
Mein kleiner Mann, es gibt keinen Fuchs mehr.
Warum? Weil wir verdorsten werden.
Er verstand meine Argumente nicht, er antwortete.
Es ist gut, einen Freund zu haben, auch wenn man sterben muss.
Ich bin froh, dass ich einen Fuchs zum Freund habe.
Er kann die Gefahr nicht ermessen, sagte ich mir.
Er ist nie hungrig oder durstig.
Ein wenig Sonnenschein ist wohl alles, was er braucht.
Da sah er mich an und antwortete auf meine Gedanken.
Ich habe auch Durst, suchen wir nach einem Brunnen?
Ich machte eine Geste voller Aussichtslosigkeit,
es war vollkommen sinnlos, nach dem Zufallsprinzip
einen Brunnen in der Weite der Wüste zu suchen.
Dennoch machten wir uns auf den Weg.
Als wir stundenlang zusammen dahin gezogen waren,
brach die Nacht herein und die Sterne begannen zu leuchten.
Ich betrachtete sie wie in einem Traum.
Vor Durst hatte ich ein leichtes Fieber.
Ich worte des kleinen Prinzen, tanzten mir durchs Bewusstsein.
Dann bist du also auch durstig, fragte ich.
Aber er beantwortete meine Frage nicht.
Er sagte einfach, das Wasser kann auch gut für das Herz sein.
Ich verstand seine Antwort nicht, aber ich schwieg.
Ich wusste, dass man ihm keine Frage stellen durfte.
Er war müde, ersetzte sich.
Ich setzte mich neben ihn.
Und nach einer Weile, sagte er, die Sterne sind schön,
weil sie an eine Blume erinnern, die wir nicht sehen.
Ich sagte, natürlich, und betrachtete die Falten des Sandes im Mondlicht.
Die Wüste ist schön, fügte er hinzu.
Und das stimmte.
Ich habe die Wüste immer geliebt.
Man sitzt auf einer Sanddühne, man sieht nichts.
Man braucht nichts zu hören.
Doch etwas leuchtet in der Stille.
Es machte die Wüste schön, sagte der kleine Prinz,
dass sie irgendwo einen Brunnen verbirgt.
Ich war überrascht.
Plötzlich verstand ich dieses geheimnisvolle Leuchten des Sandes.
Als ich ein Junge war, lebte ich in einem alten Haus.
Und die Legende erzählt, dass ein Schatz dort begraben sei.
Natürlich war niemand in der Lage, diesen Schatz zu entdecken,
oder es vielleicht nur zu versuchen.
Aber diese Legende war auf einen Zauber über dieses Haus.
Mein Haus verbarg ein Geheimnis in seinem Herzen.
Ja, sagte ich zum kleinen Prinzen,
ob es das Haus, die Sterne oder die Wüste sind,
was sie schön macht, ist unsichtbar.
Ich bin froh, sagte er, dass du ganz wie mein Fuchs denkst.
Als der kleine Prinz einschlief, nahm ich ihn auf meine Arme
und setzte den Weg fort.
Ich war bewegt.
Es schien mir als trüge ich ein zerbrechliches Juwel.
Es schien mir als gäbe es nichts zerbrechliches auf der Erde.
Im Licht des Mondscheins betrachtete ich seine Blasse Stirn,
seine geschlossenen Augen und seine im Wind zitternden Locken
und sagte mir, was ich hier sehe, ist nur eine Hülle.
Das Eigentliche ist unsichtbar.
Seine leicht geöffneten Lippen zeichneten ein halbes Lächeln.
Ich sagte mir noch,
dass mich so sehr an diesem verschlafenen kleinen Prinzen bewegt,
ist seine Treue zu einer Blume.
Es ist das Bild einer Rose, das ihn durchscheint,
wie die Flamme einer Lampe, sogar wenn er schläft.
Da kam er mir noch zerbrechlicher vor.
Man muss die Lampen schützen,
denn ein Windstoß kann sie auslöschen.
Und während ich ging, entdeckte ich bei Tagesanbruch einen Brunnen,
25. Kapitel.
Die Menschen, sagte der kleine Prinz, fahren in Schnellzügen,
aber sie wissen nicht, wohin sie wollen.
Sie ärgern sich und drehen sich im Kreis
und erfügt ihn zu, das ist der Mühe nicht wert.
Der Brunnen, den wir erreicht hatten,
waren nicht wie andere Brunnen der Sahara.
Die Brunnen in der Sahara sind nur in den Sand gegrabener Löcher.
Dieser sah aus wie ein Dorfbrunnen,
aber es gab kein Dorf hier, und ich dachte, es wäre ein Traum.
Es ist zelsam, sagte ich zum kleinen Prinzen,
alles ist bereit, die Seilwinde, der Eimer und das Seil.
Er lachte, ließ das Seil und die Winde spielen
und die Winde stöhnte wie ein altes Windrad,
wenn der Wind lange geschlafen hat.
Hörst du, sagte der kleine Prinz,
wir wecken den Brunnen auf und er singt.
Ich wollte nicht, dass er sich anstrengen musste,
überlass das Meer, sagte ich, es ist zu schwer für dich.
Langsam zog ich den Eimer bis zum Brunnenrand.
Ich stellte ihn gerade auf.
In meinen Ohren sang noch das Lied der Seilwinde
und im sich kräuselnden Wasser sah ich die Sonne zittern.
Ich habe Dorst nach diesem Wasser,
sagte der kleine Prinz, gib mir zu trinken.
Und ich verstand, was er gesucht hatte.
Ich hob den Eimer an seine Lippen,
ertrank mit geschlossenen Augen.
Es war wie ein Fest.
Dieses Wasser war viel mehr als ein Getränk.
Es war Entsprungen aus dem Fußmarsch unter den Sternen,
dem Gesang der Winde, geboren aus meiner Hände Arbeit.
Es war gut für das Herz wie ein Geschenk.
Als ich noch ein Junge war,
machten die Lichter des Christbaums die Musik
der Mitternachtsmesse die Sanftmut des Lächelns,
den eigentlichen Glanz der Weihnachtsgeschenke aus, die ich bekam.
Die Leute bei dir, sagte der kleine Prinz,
züchten 5000 Rosen in dem selben Garten
und dennoch finden sie nicht, was sie suchen.
Sie finden es nicht, antwortete ich,
und doch könnten sie es in einer einzigen Rose
oder in einem Schluck Wasser entdecken.
So ist es, antwortete ich,
und der kleine Prinz vögte hinzu,
aber die Augen sind blind,
man muss mit dem Herzen suchen.
Ich hatte getrunken, ich schöpfte wieder Atem.
Der Sand hat bei Tagesanbruch die Farbe von Honig.
Ich war auch über diese Honigfarbe glücklich.
Worüber sollte ich mir Sorgen machen?
Du musst dein Versprechen einlösen,
sagte der kleine Prinz behutsam,
der sich wieder zu mir gesetzt hatte.
Welches Versprechen?
Du weißt doch einen Maulkorb für mein Schaf.
Ich bin verantwortlich für diese Blume.
Ich nahm meine Skizzen aus der Tasche.
Der kleine Prinz betrachtete sie
und sagte mit einem Lachen,
deine Affenbrotbäume sehen wie Kohlköpfe aus.
Oh, ich war sehr stolz auf meine Affenbrotbäume.
Dein Fuchs, seine Ohren, sie sehen ein wenig wie Herna aus,
und sie sind zu lang, und er lachte wieder.
Du übersiehst, kleiner Mann, ich hatte bisher
außer einer geschlossenen Riesenschlange
und einer offenen Riesenschlange nichts anderes gezeichnet.
Oh, es wird gehen, sagte er.
Die Kinder werden es erkennen.
So skizziert ich einen Maulkorb
und schweren Herzens übergab ich ihn dem kleinen Prinzen.
Du hast Pläne, die ich nicht kenne,
aber er antwortete mir nicht.
Er sagte, weißt du, mein Sturz auf die Erde,
morgen ist der Jahrestag davon.
Dann nach einer Pause sagte er,
ich landete ganz hier in der Nähe,
und er errötete, ohne zu verstehen, warum,
fühlte ich wieder einen seltsamen Schmerz.
Da kam mir eine Frage auf.
So ist es also kein Zufall,
dass du an dem Morgen,
als ich dich vor acht Tagen traf, so ganz allein,
tausend Meilen von jeder bewohnten Gegend entfernt spazieren gingst.
Du gingst zu dem Punkt zurück, wo du gelandet warst?
Der kleine Prinz errötete erneut,
und ich fügte zögern hinzu.
Vielleicht war es der Jahrestag?
Der kleine Prinz errötete nochmals.
Nie hatte er eine Frage beantwortet,
aber wenn man errötet,
bedeutet das ja, oder nicht?
Ah, sagte ich zu ihm, ich habe Angst, doch er antwortete ruhig.
Du musst jetzt an die Arbeit,
du musst wieder zu deiner Maschine zurückgehen,
ich warte hier auf dich.
Komm morgen Abend wieder.
Aber ich war beunruhigt,
ich erinnerte mich an den Fuchs.
Man könnte ein wenig weinen,
wenn man gezähmt wurde.
26. Kapitel
Neben dem Brunnen stand die Steinmauer einer alten Ruine.
Als ich am nächsten Abend von meiner Arbeit zurückkehrte,
sah ich meinen kleinen Prinzen da sitzen,
wie er die Beine baumeln ließ.
Und ich hörte, wie er sagte,
du erinnerst dich also nicht mehr, sagte er.
Es war nicht ganz hier.
Ohne Zweifel antwortete i meine andere Stimme,
denn er sagte, ja, ja, es ist der Tag,
aber dies ist nicht der Ort.
Ich führte meinen Weg der Wand entgegen fort.
Ich glaubte weder jemanden zu sehen noch zu hören,
doch der kleine Prinz antwortete wieder,
natürlich, du wirst sehen, wo meine Spur im Sand beginnt.
Warum wartest du dort nicht auf mich?
Ich werde heute Abend da sein.
Als ich 20 Meter vor der Wand war,
sah ich immer noch nichts.
Nach einer Weile sprach der Prinz erneut,
du hast gutes Gift,
bist du sicher, dass ich nicht lange leiden werde?
Ich blieb mit schwerem Herzen stehen,
aber ich verstand noch immer nicht.
Geh jetzt weg, sagte er, ich möchte herunterkommen.
Ich heftete meine Augen an die Wand
und machte einen gewaltigen Sprung.
Da war zum kleinen Prinzen Empor gereckt
eine jener gelben Schlangen,
die dich in nur 30 Sekunden töten können.
Ich grob in meiner Tasche nach meinem Revolver und rannte los.
Doch bei dem Lärm, den ich machte,
sank die Schlange wie ein sterbender Wasserstrahl in den Sand
und ohne jede Eile schlüpfte sie
mit einem leicht metallischen Klang
zwischen den Steinen hindurch.
Gerade noch rechtzeitig erreichte ich die Wand,
um den kleinen Prinzen mit den Armen aufzufangen.
Er war bleich wie Schnee.
Was ist das für eine Geschichte?
Redest du jetzt mit Schlangen?
Ich hatte ihm seinen goldenen Schal abgenommen.
Ich hatte ihm die Schläfen benetzt und zu trinken gegeben.
Und jetzt wagte ich nicht, ihn weiterzufragen.
Er schaute mich ernst an und legte mir seinen Arm um den Hals.
Ich spürte wie sein Herz schlug,
wie das eines sterbenden Vogels,
der von einem Gewer getroffen wurde.
Er sagte, ich bin froh,
dass du den Fehler in der Maschine gefunden hast.
Du kannst jetzt nach Hause zurückkehren.
Woher weißt du das?
Ich wollte ihm gerade erzählen,
dass ich gegen alle Hoffnung meine Arbeit beenden konnte.
Er beantwortete meine Frage nicht, aber er fügte hinzu.
Auch ich werde jetzt nach Hause kommen.
Dann schwermütig.
Das ist viel weiter.
Es ist viel schwieriger.
Ich spürte, dass etwas Besonderes geschah.
Ich schloss ihn fest in meine Arme wie ein Kind.
Und doch schien es mir,
als rauschte er Kopf über in einen Abgrund,
wovor ich ihn nicht bewahren konnte.
Er hatte einen ernsten Blick, der sich in der Weite verlor.
Ich habe dein Schaf und ich habe die Kiste für das Schaf.
Und ich habe den Molkorb.
Da lächelte er schwermütig.
Ich wartete eine lange Zeit.
Ich spürte, wie er sich mehr und mehr erwärmte.
Kleine Mann, du hast Angst gehabt.
Er hatte Angst, natürlich.
Aber er lachte leicht.
Ich werde noch viel mehr Angst haben heute Abend.
Bei dem Gefühl des Unvermeidlichen lief es mir eisig über den Rücken.
Dieses Lachen nie mehr zu hören.
Ich konnte diesen Gedanken nicht ertragen.
Für mich war es wie ein Brunnen in der Wüste.
Kleiner Mann, ich will dich immer noch Lachen hören.
Aber er sagte,
heute Abend wird es ein Jahr sein.
Mein Stern befindet sich dann direkt über dem Ort,
wo ich im vergangenen Jahr abstürzte.
Kleiner Mann, ist das nicht nur ein böser Traum mit dieser Schlange
und der Abmachung und dem Stern?
Aber er beantwortete meine Frage nicht.
Er sagte, was wichtig ist, sieht man nicht, natürlich.
Es ist wie mit der Blume.
Wenn du eine Blume liebst, die auf einem Stern wohnt,
dann ist es schön, in der Nacht den Himmel zu beobachten.
Alle Sterne haben Blumen.
Natürlich, es ist wie beim Wasser.
Das, was du mir zu trinken gabst, war wie Musik.
Die Seilwinde und das Seil, du erinnerst dich?
Es war gut.
Natürlich.
Du wirst in der Nacht die Sterne betrachten.
Mein Stern ist so klein, um ihn dir zeigen zu können.
Es ist besser so.
Mein Stern wird für dich einer dieser Sterne sein.
So wirst du alle Sterne gern betrachten.
Sie werden alle deine Freunde sein.
Und dann werde ich dir ein Geschenk machen.
Er lachte wieder.
Ah, kleiner Mann, kleiner Mann, ich liebe es, dieses Lachen zu hören.
Genau das ist mein Geschenk.
Es wird sein wie Wasser.
Was meinst du damit?
Die Leute haben Sterne, die für jeden anders sind.
Für einige Reisende sind die Sterne Führer.
Für andere sind sie nichts anderes als kleine Lichter.
Für andere für die Gelehrten sind sie Probleme.
Für meinen Geschäftsmann waren sie Gold.
Aber alle diese Sterne schweigen.
Du aber, du wirst Sterne haben wie niemand anderes.
Was meinst du?
Wenn du in der Nacht den Himmel betrachtest,
weil ich auf einem von ihnen wohne,
dann wird es für dich so sein, als ob alle Sterne lachten.
Weil ich auf einem von ihnen lache.
Du allein hast Sterne, die lachen können.
Und er lachte wieder.
Und wenn du dich getröstet hast,
man tröstet sich immer,
wirst du froh darüber sein, mich gekannt zu haben.
Du wirst immer mein Freund sein.
Du wirst mit mir lachen.
Und du wirst manchmal dein Fenster öffnen.
Einfach so zum Vergnügen.
Und deine Freunde werden sehr erstaunt sein,
zu sehen, wie du lachst,
wenn du deine Blicke auf den Himmel richtest.
Dann sagst du, ja, die Sterne bringen mich immer zum Lachen.
Und sie werden dich für verrückt halten.
Dann werde ich dir einen schönen Scherz bereitet haben.
Und er lachte wieder.
Es wird sein, als hätte ich dir nicht die Sterne geschenkt,
sondern kleine Glocken, die lachen können.
Und er lachte wieder.
Dann wurde er ernst.
Heute Nacht, du weißt schon, kommen nicht.
Ich will dich nicht verlassen.
Ich werde aussehen, als hätte ich Schmerzen.
Es würde ein wenig aussehen, als ob ich stürbe.
Es ist so, kommen nicht es anzusehen.
Es lohnt sich nicht.
Ich will dich nicht verlassen.
Aber er sorgte sich.
Ich sage dir das.
Es ist auch wegen der Schlange.
Sie soll dich nicht beißen.
Schlangen sind böse.
Sie beißen aus reiner Freude.
Ich will dich nicht verlassen.
Aber etwas beruhigte ihn.
Es ist wahr, dass sie für einen zweiten Bissen
kein Gift mehr haben.
In dieser Nacht bemerkte ich nicht, wie er losging.
Er verschwand völlig lautlos.
Als es mir gelang, ihn einzuholen,
ging er mit schnellen Schritten weiter.
Er sagte mir nur, ah, du bist hier.
Dann nahm er mich bei der Hand.
Aber er war immer noch voller Sorge.
Das ist falsch von dir.
Es wird dir leidzufügen.
Ich werde aussehen, als sei ich tot.
Doch es wird nicht wahr sein.
Ich schwieg.
Du verstehst doch, es ist weit.
Ich kann diesen Körper nicht mitnehmen.
Er ist zu schwer.
Ich schwieg.
Mein Körper wird hier bleiben,
wie eine alte verlassene Hülle.
Man muss nicht traurig sein,
wegen solch alter Hüllen.
Ich schwieg.
Er war ein wenig entmutigt.
Aber er gab sich weiter Mühe.
Weißt du, es wird schön sein.
Auch ich freue mich auf die Sterne.
Alle Sterne werden brunnen für mich sein,
mit einer verrosteten Winde.
Alle Sterne werden mir einen Trank zureichen.
Ich schwieg.
Das wird viel Spaß machen.
Du wirst 500 Millionen Glocken haben.
Ich werde 500 Millionen Brunnen haben.
Und er schwieg, denn er weinte.
Da ist es.
Lass mich einen Schritt allein gehen.
Und ersetzte sich, weil er Angst hatte.
Er sagte, weißt du, meine Blume.
Ich bin für sie verantwortlich.
Und sie ist so schwach.
Und sie ist so einfältig.
Sie hat vier Dornen,
die sie nicht gegen die Welt schützen können.
Ich setzte mich, weil ich nicht mehr stehen konnte.
Er sagte, ja, das ist alles.
Er wartete noch ein wenig, dann stand er auf.
Er machte einen Schritt.
Ich konnte mich nicht mehr bewegen.
Es war nichts, als mein gelber Blitz an seinem Knöchel.
Er blieb für einen Moment still stehen.
Er weinte nicht.
Er fiel sachte wie das Blatt eines Baumes.
Nicht einmal ein Geräusch machte es,
als er in den Sand fiel.
27. Kapitel.
Nun sind es schon sechs Jahre her.
Ich habe diese Geschichte noch niemandem erzählt.
Meine Kameraden, die ich wieder sah,
waren sehr froh, mich am Leben zu sehen.
Ich war traurig, aber ihnen sagte ich,
ich bin erschöpft.
Jetzt habe ich mich ein wenig getröstet.
Das heißt, nicht ganz,
aber ich weiß, dass er auf seinen Planeten zurückgekehrt ist.
Denn bei Tagesanbruch konnte ich seinen Körper nicht finden.
Es war kein sehr schwerer Körper
und in der Nacht liebe ich es, den Sternen zuzuhören.
Sie sind wie 500 Millionen Glöckchen.
Doch jetzt geschieht etwas Außergewöhnliches.
Als ich den Maulkorb für den kleinen Prinzen zeichnete,
vergaß ich ganz der Zeichnung, ein Lederband hinzuzufügen.
Er wird wohl kaum in der Lage gewesen sein,
dem Schaf diesen Maulkorb anzulegen.
Ich fragte mich, was geschah wohl auf seinem Planeten?
Vielleicht hat das Schaf die Blume doch gefressen.
Manchmal sage ich mir, bestimmt nicht.
Der kleine Prinz deckt seine Blume jeden Tag
mit seiner Glasglocke zu
und er passt auf sein Schaf,
das macht mich glücklich
und alle Sterne lachen leise.
Manchmal sage ich mir aber auch,
es sind hin und wieder unachtsam
und das reicht vollkommen.
Vielleicht vergaß er eines Abends die Glasglocke
oder das Schaf verschwand einfach geräuschlos in der Nacht.
Dann verwandern sich die Glöckchen allesamt in Tränen.
Das ist ein großes Schaf.
Das ist ein großes Geheimnis.
Für euch, die ihr den kleinen Prinzen liebt
und auch für mich ist das nicht einerlei,
wenn irgendwo im Universum ein Schaf ist,
das wir nicht kennen, wenn es eine Rose gefressen hat oder nicht.
Betrachtet euch den Himmel.
Fragt euch, ja oder nein?
Hat das Schaf die Blume gefressen oder nicht?
Dann werdet ihr sehen, wie sich alles verändert.
Und keiner von den großen Leuten
wird jemals verstehen, wie wichtig das ist.
Für mich ist das die schönste
und die traurigste Landschaft in der Welt.
Es ist die gleiche wie die vorherige,
doch ich habe sie noch einmal gezeichnet,
um euch das ganze Ausmaß zu zeigen.
Genau hier,
erschien der kleine Prinz auf der Erde
und hier verschwand er auch wieder.
Schaut ihr euch aufmerksam an,
um sicherzugehen, dass ihr sie wieder erkennt,
wenn ihr vielleicht eines Tages durch die Wüste in Afrika reist.
Und wenn ihr dorthin kommt,
dann geht nicht gleich weiter.
Ich bitte euch,
nehmt euch die Zeit
und wartet ein wenig.
Wenn dann ein Kind zu euch kommt
und es lacht, wenn es goldene Haare hat
und keine Antworten auf eure Fragen gibt,
dann werdet ihr wissen, wer das ist.
Dann seid so nett.
Lasst mich nicht so traurig.
Schreibt mir, sobald er wiedergekommen ist.
Wenn dir die Geschichte gefallen hat,
schau dich gerne auf meinem Kanal um.
Bestimmt findest du dann noch etwas,
das dir auch gefallen könnte.
Bis dahin wünsche ich dir alles Gute.
Bleib gesund, dein Joachim Friedrich.